nous allons commencer
l'audition et j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir en votre nom à tous
monsieur pape ndiaye ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
l'ordre du jour de la séance publique
nous a contraint la semaine dernière à
décaler votre audition à aujourd'hui et
nous vous remercions pour votre
compréhension
nous sommes très heureux monsieur le
ministre de vous entendre aujourd'hui au
sud au sein de notre commission qui est
vous le savez très attaché et très
attentive aux enjeux de l'enseignement
et nous souhaitons que ces d'audition
soit pour vous l'occasion de nous
présenter vos priorités pour les mois à
venir mais aussi votre feuille de route
pour l'ensemble de la législature nous
aurons bien sûr également l'occasion de
vous interroger sur des points précis et
à c'était cet instant il ya environ une
quarantaine d'inscrits en plus des
orateurs donc nous vous voyez que les
collègues sont vraiment très engagé et
très attentif à tous ces sujets et bien
que nous soyons au milieu des vacances
scolaires nous avons toutes et tous en
tête les chances de la rentrée dans un
mois et avec elle plusieurs
interrogations nous savons que les
concours de recrutement de professeurs
des écoles et d'enseignants du second
degré ont cette année été marquée par un
faible nombre de candidats ce qui a pu
laisser craindre que des postes
demeurent vacants à la rentrée et cissé
situation présente un aspect
conjoncturel lié au déplacement des
concours en fin de master 2 il est
indéniable que la question de
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
est une question structurelle vous avez
annoncé différentes mesures pour
améliorer cette attractivité au travers
d'une revalorisation salariale d'une
part mais aussi une plus grande
autonomie laissée aux équipes
pédagogiques d'autre part et qui fera
l'objet d'expérimentations pouvez nous
nous en dire d'avantagé nous donner des
éléments précis notamment de calendrier
de périmètre ou encore de montant de ces
mesures et pouvait nous et vous
également précisé les contours de la
grande concertation sur l'école qui aura
lieu cet automne avec le corps
enseignant
vous avez par ailleurs indiqué dans le
courrier que vous avez dressé fin juin
l'ensemble des enseignants que la
consolidation des savoirs fondamentaux
était l'une des priorités de votre
ministère c'est le cas depuis plusieurs
années déjà
et pouvait nous pouvez vous nous
préciser de quelle manière cette
priorité se concrétisera dans les mois à
venir
s'agissant par exemple de la
réintégration dans l'enseignement de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun de la
classe de première annoncé début juin
pouvez vous nous confirmer que les
établissements seront bien en mesure de
le mettre en oeuvre d'ici la rentrée
scolaire prochaine
enfin nous connaissons depuis plusieurs
semaines des vagues de chaleur qui
risque de se généraliser dans les années
à venir le lien entre école et
environnement est essentiel tant pour
sensibiliser et former les générations à
venir à ces enjeux qui doit imprégner
l'ensemble des enseignements qui leur
sont dispensés que pour leur permettre
d'étudier dans de bonnes conditions
en adaptant le bâti scolaire à ce
contexte et en le rendant plus sobre
comment ces questions seront elles
traitées et avec quels moyens dans les
années à venir
monsieur le ministre maintenant je vous
laisse la parole pour des propos
liminaires et ensuite nos collègues
prendront la parole pour deux minutes
pour chaque orateur vous répondrez à ce
premier bouquet de question et ensuite
nous reprendrons les questions des
collègues par environ une dizaine de
questions chacune c'est à vous
merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
c'est un plaisir et un honneur pour moi
que d'échanger avec vous de prendre le
temps d'échanger sur des questions à
l'évidence essentiel pour notre pays
l'éducation de nos enfants l'avenir de
notre pays l'avenir de la république
quoi de plus central quoi de plus
quelle quelle mission quelques belles
missions
je crois véritablement que c'est une
tâche qui est à la hauteur
de du travail que nous allons engager ce
travail il se décline de plusieurs
manières d'abord par la rentrée et je
serais heureux de répondre aux questions
que vous pourriez avoir à propos de la
rentrée que nous saisissons cette année
dans des circonstances un peu
particulières
compte tenu des difficultés de
recrutement auquel madame la présidente
vous avez fait justement allusion est
également d'autres difficultés ou
d'autres points de vigilance sur
lesquels nous nous penchons en lien avec
les collectivités territoriales
mais au delà de la rentrée il y a bien
sûr des questions de fond qui se pose
est que nous avons décliné d'ores et
déjà dans le cadre d'une circulaire de
rentrée plutôt destinés aux personnels
de l'éducation nationale
également dans le cadre d'une lettre aux
professeurs qui précisait un certain
nombre de grands axes de la politique de
ce ministère
impulsée par la première ministre et le
président de la république dans le cadre
des engagements qui ont été pris par le
président particulièrement lors de la
campagne présidentielle
je vais donner je voudrais donc
développer ces points en mettant de côté
peut-être la rentrée puisque certains et
certaines d'entre vous y reviendrons
mais je veux simplement à propos de la
rentrée souligné la question du
recrutement des professeurs ces
questions qui a été qui revenue de façon
très très très saillantes
recrutement dans le premier degré qui
pose problème dans les académies
francilienne particulièrement les
académies de créteil et versailles et
dans le second degré à l'échelle
nationale pour quelques disciplines
notamment les langues vivantes et la
technologie qui sont encore
en tension et en tensions fortes pour
nous et c'est évidemment un sujet de
travail dans chaque académie afin qu'il
y ait un professeur dans chaque classe à
la rentrée et c'est une situation plus
difficile que d'habitude en raison d'un
marché du travail très tendue également
en raison du passage du recrutement du
m1 ou m2 qui a provisoirement taris le
vivier de recrutement je pourrais
revenir là dessus si vous le souhaitez
nous avons également un point de
vigilance à propos des chauffeurs de
cars scolaires pour la rentrée puisque
il y à des difficultés de recrutement de
ce côté cela n'est pas un autre main
directement ce sont les régions qui
s'occupe de cela mais nous surveillons
la situation en lien avec les régions
est également en lien avec le ministère
des transports au-delà de ces points
nous insistons sur quelques grands axes
que vous avez bien que vous avez rappelé
en partie madame la présidente le
premier le premier axe c'est celui des
savoirs fondamentaux et à cet égard nous
nous inscrivons en ligne en continuité
avec le précédent quinquennat dans la
mesure où l'acquisition des savoirs
fondamentaux particulièrement en
français et en mathématiques constitue
lui des priorités du ministère cela se
matérialise par du côté du premier degré
l'insistance mise sur ces deux
disciplines ce qui n'est pas exclusif
d'autres savoirs et du déploiement
d'autres pratiques et d'autres
d'autres savoirs disons disciplinaire
bien entendu c'est également le cas dans
le secondaire avec comme nouveauté pour
la rentrée comme vous l'avez rappelé
l'introduction de l'heure et demie de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun pour
les classes de première à titre
optionnel pour cette année en
envisageant de rendre cette heure et
demie de mathématiques obligatoire à
partir de la rentrée 2023 la réflexion
sur les mathématiques qui est ancienne
qui a été matérialisée par plusieurs
rapports je pense en particulier aux
rapports villani torossian il y a
quelques années et d'autres travaux qui
ont été menés par les conseils les
différents conseils du ministère de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
ne repose pas simplement sur la joue
quantitatif d'heure de mathématiques la
france est un des pays en europe ou d'un
point de vue quantitatif les
mathématiques sont les plus enseigné
entre le cp et la terminale force est de
constater que les résultats ne sont pas
complètement à la hauteur à l'exception
d'une élite mathématiques qui est tout à
fait remarquable mais qui masque parfois
un niveau médiocre moyen niveau moyen
beaucoup plus problématique est donc
nous nous penchons non seulement sur la
question de cette heure et demie de
mathématiques en première mais également
sur la pédagogie des mathématiques sur
la manière d'enseigner des mathématiques
et cela fait l'objet de travaux et de
réflexions dont on pourra parler si vous
le souhaitez donc les savoirs
fondamentaux nous maintenons cette
ligne là cette continuité avec les
postes afférents bien entendu je
remarque à cet égard que nous n'avons
pas de pour cette rentrée de difficultés
particulières du côté des mathématiques
par exemple en dépit de l'heure et demie
de mathématiques qui vient d'être
introduite pour les classes de première
la deuxième ligne force c'est une
politique d'égalité des chances vous le
savez en effet la france ne se classe
pas bien à leshan à l'échelle européenne
pour ce qui concerne la capacité de
l'école à réduire sinon à effacer les
inégalités sociales les inégalités de
naissance l'école française tend plutôt
à reproduire les inégalités de naissance
et c'est évidemment quelque chose un
sujet majeur sur lequel nous devons nous
pencher c'est le cas depuis évidemment
longtemps il ya des politiques d'égalité
des chances depuis longtemps mais il y à
des travaux à mener il y à des
réflexions à poursuivre sur la carte de
sur la carte de l'éducation prioritaire
sur les investissements à faire ici sur
la simplification aussi d'un
millefeuille qui s'est constitué au fil
des années il y à aussi à poursuivre des
efforts qui ont été entrepris ces
dernières années en particulier le
dédoublement des classes de grande
section de maternelle qui n'est pas
achevée dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaires ainsi que le dédoublement
des cp et ses vins en rép ehret plus qui
lui est achevée
le troisième la troisième ligne force
c'est la question du bien-être des
élèves cette question ce porte ou se
pose avec une attention renouvelée
depuis la crise sanitaire nous avons été
alertés en effet par un
état de santé particulièrement de santé
psy chic
voire psychiatriques des élèves enfants
et adolescents qui il faut le dire est
plutôt préoccupant et c'est donc une
question sur laquelle nous devons
absolument travailler avec force en
dépit de l'état également difficile de
du système de santé scolaire nous
pourrons revenir sur cette question si
vous le souhaitez le bien-être des
élèves ce n'est pas qu'une question
marginale c'est comme le professeur
stanislas dehaene le président du
conseil supérieur du conseil supérieur
de l'éducation le scientifique pardon de
l'éducation le disait il ya quelques
semaines une question décisive pour les
conditions d'apprentissage pour la
qualité d'apprentissage de nos élèves et
donc nous devons avancer sur ces
questions ça comprend également la
question de l'activité physique et des
initiatives ont été prises récemment
dans la lignée des annonces du président
de la république avec en particulier la
demi heure d'activité physique
quotidienne qui devient obligatoire dans
toutes les écoles à partir de la rentrée
elle existait jusque là sous une forme
expérimentale sept mille écoles sur 49
pile pour l'année précédente un autre
point important
tient et je poursuis ce que vous avez
souligné madame la présidente aux
questions d'environnement sur lesquels
le ministère de l'éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse doivent également
se pencher et travailler les questions
d'environnement ne relève pas simplement
ou seulement du ministère de
l'environnement de l'écologie mais
également de toutes les sphères
gouvernementales y compris de
l'éducation nationale cela peut se
décliner de plusieurs manières par le
contenu d'abord des programmes
l'inspection générale
se penche sur cette question par le
biais d'un rapport qui est en
travail aujourd'hui mais nous avons
aussi la question préoccupante à
certains égards et pas partout bien
entendu du bâti scolaire d'un bâti non
pas le plus récent mais d'un bâti ancien
ou moyennement anciens qui s'avère peu
adaptés aux vagues de chaleur que nous
subissons particulièrement au mois de
juin il est probable que ces vagues de
chaleur vont se multiplier dans les
années à venir et donc nous devons aussi
travailler en lien avec les
collectivités territoriales
sur la question du bâti scolaire et
réfléchir bien entendu avec les
collectivités territoriales qui ont la
main là dessus à la meilleure manière de
deux d'améliorer et la résistance du
bâti aux vagues de chaleur là des
bitumes isation le fait de planter le
fait également d'aménager parfois des
aménagements qui ne sont pas très
coûteux mais nous avons un rôle en la
matière que nous entendons tenir enfin
il est une question
que j'évoquais indirectement en parlant
de la rentrée scolaire qui est celle de
la revalorisation du métier d'enseignant
cette revalorisation n'est pas
simplement financière c'est aussi une
révalorisation que je qualifierais de
social et de morale en effet beaucoup
d'enseignants et à juste titre le
sentiment d'un métier qui est déclassé
d'un métier qui est dévalorisé de ne
plus être considéré avec le respect l
autorité qui pourtant leur sont dues
dans la société française en général et
nous avons de multiples témoignages qui
vont dans ce sens notre objectif c'est
de revaloriser l'autorité morale des
enseignants ce qui passe en effet par
des revalorisations salariales
bien entendu c'est tout à fait
dispensable mais pas seulement et je
serai très attachés au respect à
l'autorité ou comment dirais-je à la
position sociale des enseignants dans la
société française qui s'est dégradée qui
s'est effritée au fil des années et
c'est quelque chose que nous ne pouvons
accepter l'école nouvelles se fera elle
elle prendra un nouvel élan avec les
enseignants avec la communauté éducative
en général il est donc indispensable de
procéder à cette forme de revalorisation
pour cela nous allons échanger tout au
long de l'automne sur les questions
relatives à leur revalorisation
financière ça c'est à l'échelle
nationale de même que sur les missions
nouvelles que nous pourrions proposer
aux enseignants et qui ont été
esquissées par le président de la
république ces derniers mois missions
qui peuvent être et qui seront assorties
elle aussi de revalorisation financière
et sur lesquels je pourrais vous fournir
des précisions si vous le souhaitez
parallèlement à ces échanges nationaux
nous allons en effet madame la
présidente
mettre en place des débats à l'échelle
des écoles non pas un grenelle de
l'éducation une grande réunion je dirais
dans sa solennité au niveau du ministère
mais plutôt des centaines des milliers
de débat à l'échelle des écoles pour que
les communautés éducatives échangent sur
leurs écoles si je prends l'exemple de
l'école lamartine 2
mâcon
je m'aventure je ne sais pas s'il ya une
école lamartine à mâcon mais ça n'est
qu'un exemple sûrement et bien le débat
qui aura lieu portera sur l'école
lamartine de mâcon
afin d'imaginer un projet
d'établissement un nouveau projet
pédagogique qui s'établira selon et avec
notre soutien avec également les
précisions les documentations
les
les un ensemble de deux programmes et de
propositions que nous serons aussi amené
à établir donc nous souhaitons des
renouvellements par le bas si je puis
dire à l'échelle des écoles plutôt que
des renouvellement par le haut nous
souhaitons une forme de débat
démocratique que des débats
démocratiques puissent avoir lieu dans
nos écoles collèges et lycées à la
rentrée à partir desquels dans le droit
fil de ce qui se fait à marseille dans
59 établissements à l'heure actuelle des
des formes de projets avec des
possibilités pour les équipes
d'enseignants les équipes
administratives mais aussi les parents
d'élèves et d'une manière générale la
communauté éducative
d'imaginer des solutions d'imaginer
aussi des formes pédagogiques nouvelles
j'ai eu l'occasion de me rendre à
marseille au mois de juin j'accompagnais
le président de la république pour voir
ce qui était expérimenté dans une école
primaire du côté des mathématiques
puisque c'était la discipline qui était
discuté et expérimenté à marseille dans
un laboratoire de mathématiques qui
proposait aux élèves une forme plus
ludique plus pratique de faire des
mathématiques qui correspond d'ailleurs
à ce qui se fait de façon tout à fait
courante dans beaucoup de pays d'europe
c'est donc ce sont donc ces débats là
que nous souhaitons mettre en place que
nous allons mettre en place à partir de
la fin septembre et du mois d'octobre et
les projets les plus aboutis
feront l'objet d'un financement qui sera
élaborée qui sera proposé dans le cours
de l'année 2023 donc nous avons pour cet
automne sur le métier si je puis dire à
la fois une négociation nationale pour
la revalorisation des enseignants est
également des débats locaux
diffracté dans toutes les écoles et
établissements
du pays pour
donner aux acteurs eux mêmes la
possibilité de penser et d'intervenir
dans le projet pédagogique dans les
projets pédagogiques qui seront élaborés
voilà ce qui étant en cours pour
l'automne et puis au delà bien entendu
la mise en place de ces projets
pédagogiques la mise en place de ces
nouvelles missions pour les enseignants
à partir de la rentrée 2023 et sur un
fondement qui sera un fondement de
volontariat pour les enseignants
concernés voilà ce qui est en jeu et
bien entendu il ya d'autres éléments
dans l'est
grandes têtes de chapitres que je viens
d'indiquer mais je serais heureux d'y
répondre si vous m'interrogez dans cette
direction voilà ce que je voulais dire
afin de lancer nos échanges mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la présidente
merci monsieur le ministre effectivement
vous avez ouvert beaucoup de têtes de
chapitres et je ne doute pas je suis
même certaines que nos collègues que mes
collègues vont s'y engouffrer et donc
pour le groupe renaissance je laisse la
parole à anne grenier rares
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre à l'occasion de cette
première audition devant notre
commission en tant qu'enseigne adjointe
à l'éducation à lyon j'aurais beaucoup
de questions à vous poser sur le
bien-être des élèves où le bâti scolaire
mais j'ai choisi au nom du groupe des
députés renaissance de vous interroger
sur l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant qu'est véritablement pour
nous le sujet central en ce moment cette
attractivité ce métier fait face à une
crise d'attractivité pardon que ce soit
dans le premier le second degré des
postes offerts aux concours de
recrutement restent chaque année non
pourvus cette année encore nous avons
constaté une baisse du nombre de
candidats admissibles au concours de
professeur des écoles et du capes dans
certaines disciplines le nombre de
candidats s'avère même inférieur au
nombre de postes à pourvoir et le nombre
de démissions d'enseignants augmente
également ses signes ne trompent pas
nous sommes face à une crise des
vocations pour y faire face vous avez
déclaré vouloir créer un choc
d'attractivité un choc qui comporterait
une revalorisation salariale ainsi que
des améliorations d'autres types dans la
gestion de la carrière des enseignants
au fil des années nous avons constaté
une érosion relative des revenus des
enseignants alors que dans le même temps
le un niveau de qualification lui a
augmenté ce constat et je crois
aujourd'hui largement partagé par
ailleurs le rapport annuel de la
médiatrice de l'éducation nationale paru
il ya peu insiste sur deux points plus
particulier que je souhaite cité car ils
ont été abordés par des professeurs de
mathématiques que j'ai réunis il ya peu
dans ma circonscription le sujet de la
reconnaissance et de la valorisation de
la carrière antérieure pour celles et
ceux qui choisissent le métier
d'enseignant après une première carrière
professionnelle ce sont là des vocations
qui nous faut je pense considéré aussi
et celui de la mobilité de l'affectation
en début de carrière que ce soit pour
nos jeunes professeurs comme pour ses
seconds carrière monsieur le ministre
vous avez en partie aborder ce sujet
dans votre propos liminaire mais
pourriez vous nous préciser la méthode
prévu pour améliorer l'attractivité de
ce beau métier d'enseignant et notamment
son volet revalorisation salariale je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
pour le rassemblement et départ
nationale la parole est à roger judo
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous vous êtes exprimé pendant
20 minutes et honnêtement sans être
désobligeant je ne vois toujours pas de
politique éducative
lorsque vous nous avez présenté
s'il vous plaît la parole est à monsieur
roger je suis doué a dit merci donc les
résultats sont en baisse ou le dit très
bien vous avez repéré qu'il y avait une
fracture sociale et de fractures
scolaires mais il n'y a rien de tangible
dans ce que vous proposez et je voudrais
rappeler simplement que la réalité comme
disait brel et concrète et que nous
attendons des mesures tangibles de
revalorisation en phase de revalidation
de pardon de rénovation de
l'enseignement des fondamentaux
savez vous par exemple qu'en 1945 il y
avait trois cent soixante six demi
journées d'enseignement et 30 heures par
semaine et qu'aujourd'hui nous en sommes
à 316 demi-journée et 24 heures par
semaine peut-être y aurait-il là une
piste à explorer le collège quant à lui
est le maillon faible du système et
d'une romance colère tout le monde le
dit y compris françois bayrou drame
ouvrages célèbres envisagez vous de le
réformer enfin quant au lycée devient sa
propre caricature puisque le niveau en
mathématiques en baisse depuis 40 ans
selon le rapport du comité de
consultation
nepad est toujours pas comment dirais-je
une de vos priorités le baccalauréat
blanc caire achève de discréditer
l'examen terminal qu'est le baccalauréat
et vous ne tranchait pas entre un examen
de fin d'études secondaires et un examen
qui soit véritablement diplômant de
l'enseignement supérieur enfin
s'agissant des professeurs vous voulez
organiser une vaste consultation la
crise de recrutement en fait est de
nature systémique vous avez votre
affaire de grande consultation a déjà
été explorée par vos prédécesseurs la
commission thélot en 2004 avis regarder
ça très près vous devriez lire le
rapport et la commission pochard en 2008
en avait fait autant le temps n'est plus
au diagnostic mais monsieur le ministre
il est à l'action
la parole pour les filles et à paul
vannier
[Musique]
axe clément
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre votre prédécesseur était à la
tête d'un ministère élargi puisque en
plus de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse il était aussi ministre des
sports à cette aune le périmètre de vos
prérogatives et considérablement
rabougri aussi rétrograde qu'il y
paraisse vous partager bien la tutelle
de la jeunesse avec le ministère des
armées quant à l'enseignement
professionnel il est placé sous la
tutelle conjointe de votre ministère et
de celui du travail c'est une première
depuis 1920 l' architecture
gouvernementale place ainsi en marge du
périmètre de l'éducation nationale près
du tiers des lycéens elles annoncent
leur transfert progressif vers le
ministère du travail et avec lui
l'abandon des finalités émancipatrice et
qualifiante de cette voie d'excellence
qui scolarise 650 mille élèves dans ce
cas vous revendiquez la poursuite des
contre-réformes du lycée du baccalauréat
et de parcours sur toutes portent
atteinte au caractère républicain du
service public de l'éducation
garant de l'égalité de traitement et
d'accès de tous les élèves la contre
réforme du lycée et conduites à
l'instauration d'un enseignement à
géométrie variable différent d'un
établissement à un autre
la contre réforme du baccalauréat a fait
disparaître le diplôme national du
baccalauréat pour le remplacer par des
diplômes locaux dont la valeur dépend de
la réputation du lycée dans lesquelles
ils sont passés parcours substitue une
sélection aussi injuste qu'insupportable
à l'entrée du supérieur sur fond de
crise du recrutement et d'augmentation
des démissions vous annoncé vouloir
porter de nouveau coup au statut des
enseignants rémunération variable
nouvelles tâches temps de formation en
dehors du service enfin vous annoncer la
généralisation de l'expérimentation
marseillaise c'est à dire du modèle de
l'école entreprises aussi monsieur lune
ministre ma question est elle simple
etes-vous le ministre de l'éducation
nationale ou celui de sondés tellement
la parole pour les républicains est à
alexandre portier
madame la présidente là monsieur le
ministre qui sera capable durant ce
mandat monsieur le ministre de sortir du
discours de toulon le tout ne va pas si
mal
pour regarder les choses en face avec
lucidité le fait que le ministère que
vous dirigez désormais ne parvient plus
à trouver des enseignants doit être
considéré comme un graphe finale d'
alerte plus de 4000 postes sur 27 me ne
sont pas pourvus à la rentrée 2022
est-ce qu'on va devoir faire appel à des
enseignants retraités fermer des classes
est ce qu'on va devoir fermer des écoles
est-ce qu'il faudra verser des
indemnités aux familles pour chaque
heure de cours perdues le recrutement
ponctuelles d'agents contractuels ne
suffira pas une série de pansements ne
forme pas une politique nationale et
nous n'arrêterons pas une hémorragie
avec des pansements alors d'où vient le
mal comme vous l'avez indiqué sans doute
du déclassement violent que subissent
nos enseignants depuis plusieurs
décennies l'école républicaine
n'apparaît plus pour les parents comme
pour les enseignants eux mêmes comme la
voix de l'ascension sociale alors il ya
évidemment le salaire que vous avez
évoquées diplômé d'un bac +5 qu'un
professeur début de sa carrière en étant
rémunéré 1450 net par mois soit 1,4 smic
comment fait rêver les têtes les me fait
d'autant que la stratégie d'élévation du
niveau de recrutement n'a pas donné lieu
à une pause rémunération et on en voit
les conséquences nos meilleurs esprits
déserte aujourd'hui d'enseignants et
puis soyons clairs ce n'est pas
seulement d'un salaire dont les
enseignants ont besoin c'est d'abord de
considération et de soutien seulement 4%
des professeurs aujourd'hui considèrent
que leur métier est valorisé par la
société un quart des enseignants
s'interrogent sur la voie
professionnelle qu'ils ont choisi donc
avant de parler chiffres il faudra
évidemment nous parler l'humain car
l'icône n'est pas une grande garderie
n'a pas vocation à se soumettre aux
pressions extérieures ni à se plier en
quatre pour répondre aux desiderata de
chacun l'école ce n'est pas venez comme
vous êtes car comment former
efficacement et avec exigence comment
transmettre nos valeurs républicaines
dans une école laissée au bon vouloir de
chacun l'école n'est rien sur l'autorité
de l'enseignant autorités qui est trop
souvent bafouée par les élèves être sont
remises en cause par les parents qui
sont peut-être un peu trop dans les
écoles et puis trop peu souvent soutenue
surtout par la hiérarchie que faire que
faire vous donc mai le ministre pourrait
l'affirmer cette autorité merci merci
monsieur le député la parole était à
géraldine banier pour les démocrates
si madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre l'éducation avec la culture un
style les ferments de la cohésion
sociale du civisme sans lesquels une
nation n'a aucune force c'est aussi la
voie de l'égalité des chances et
d'échappement au déterminisme que une
voie qui doit être la plus empruntables
possible par le plus grand nombre faute
de quoi notre école rate son objectif
nos professeurs ainsi que l'ensemble des
membres de nos communautés éducatives
ont ainsi un rôle fondamental rôle qui
doit sans cesse être appelé et jamais
perdu de vue par nos concitoyens le
groupe des démocrates et indépendants se
réjouit de voir que bat enfin pris à
bras le corps le problème d'attractivité
des métiers et des conditions de travail
dans un contexte de crise de recrutement
inédit qui pourrait mettre en péril la
qualité de l'enseignement nos
professeurs ont besoin d'un soutien sans
ambiguïté sans suspicion de tous alors
faut-il le rappeler qu'ils font le choix
de transmettre partout en france motivés
d'abord et avant tout par le sens de
leur mission le métier méconnu dans ce
qu'ils exigent de l'investissement et de
préoccupations et novations quotidienne
il faut certainement mieux le mettre en
lumière au cours de la dernière
législature des premiers leviers ont été
actionnées amélioration de la
rémunération début de carrière des
indemnités en référé plus pour les
enseignants les avs sont devenus ash
avec une nouvelle grille indiciaire une
formation de 60 heures ce travail est
évidemment à poursuivre et vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre propos liminaire nous
serons également à vos côtés monsieur le
ministre sur certains points qui nous
paraissent majeur préserver le temps des
enseignements fondamentaux
le français les mathématiques notamment
grignoter au fil des ans par un temps
scolaire qui se perd parfois en
saupoudrage annexes inefficace faire de
la voie professionnelle une vraie vous à
d'excellence avec une découverte des
métiers accrue à partir de la cinquième
pour que ses futurs élèves sont en
capacité de choisir est mieux valorisé
et plus jeunes dans leur talent
améliorer l'orientation des lycéens pour
qu'ils réussissent dans le supérieur
dans les voies qui leur offre un avenir
voici le message que nous voulons pas
faire passer deux questions peut-être
venu pour le du terrain est il prévu de
faire appel aux candidats sur les
complémentaires du capcir pub pour
pallier les manques est-ce que les isles
avaient dès qu'ils ont 6 ans
d'ancienneté peuvent d'ores et déjà
poursuivre leur contrat en septembre
ainsi que les avais sache après trois
ans merci madame la députée pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés mais
dampha tiacoh doit achi
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre ma question porte sur le
pôle médico-social les établissements
scolaires à la veille d'une rentrée qui
s'annonce très compliquée voire
catastrophique le pôle médico-social
scolaire est lui aussi en grande
souffrance au risque de la chaise vide
de professeurs s'ajoute celui de
l'absence totale d' accompagnement
médical psychologique
ou sociale pour des milliers d'élèves en
effet nous sommes très inquiets de la
baisse dramatique des effectifs de ces
personnels qui conduit à une véritable
pénurie sans l'ombre d'une réponse
concrète en la matière les chiffres pour
mon département la seine saint denis
font froid dans le dos depuis fin 2021
il manque 50 postes d'infirmières
scolaires
22 postes 22 établissements non plus
d'assistantes sociales près de 50% des
médecins scolaires ne sont pas présents
dans les établissements
à savoir que pour le chiffre académique
ses 36 % ce qui est déjà beaucoup trop
vous le savez monsieur le ministre le
malaise est bien plus profond que des
simples chiffres en effet comme pour
bien d'autres métiers de l'éducation
nationale le métier d'infirmier
scolaires ou de psychologues n'attire
plus et manque de reconnaissance ces
personnels sont souvent affectés dans un
bassin c'est à dire avec un nombre
d'établissements autour de trois quatre
voire cinq ils sont amenés à travailler
avec des équipes éducatives trop
nombreuses ce déplacement d'un hit se
déplaçant pardon d'un établissement à
l'autre la tâche est souvent rude et des
conditions de travail sont plutôt
pénible pourtant ce pôle médico-social
contribuer même indispensable à la
réussite de nos élèves il accompagne
ceux qui sont le plus en difficulté ceux
qui sont en situation de handicap et
ceux qui donnent des signes de
souffrance psychologique suite à la
crise sanitaire cette souffrance s'est
accrue beaucoup d'élèves sont
aujourd'hui en décrochage scolaire je le
redis encore une fois la fonction du
pôle médico-social est essentielle donc
ma question comment enfin redonner de
l'attractivité de la reconnaissance à
ces métiers comment s'assurer que les
établissements fonctionnent avec un une
équipe éducative complète merci merci
madame la députée pour le groupe horizon
et apparentés jérémy patrier like us
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre permettez moi tout d'abord au
nom des députés du groupe horizon de
vous féliciter de votre nomination à la
tête de ce ministère est essentielle qui
est à la fois la fabrique de la
république le garant de l'émancipation
de nos jeunes compatriotes
l'instrument de la cohésion sociale et
de l'égalité des chances pour les
députés horizon l'éducation est la mère
des réformes edouard philippe aura
l'occasion de formuler sa vision à
quelques propositions dans un livre à
paraître à l'automne en attendant
permettez moi d'insister sur les points
d' alerte qui sont autant de défis pour
notre système éducatif la nécessité de
répondre avec force à la crise des
vocations et mes collègues en ont parlé
l'une des raisons de montée des extrêmes
dans votre pays s'explique par le
sentiment de déclassement d'abandon
particulièrement dans les territoires
ruraux une classe qui ferme pendant des
semaines des mois parce qu'un professeur
n'est pas remplacé c'est le sentiment d
des laissés pour compte que l'état n'est
pas au rendez vous
c'est un problème complexe majeur auquel
il nous faut collectivement trouver des
réponses fortes la volonté ensuite
d'associer pleinement les élus locaux
aux décisions de fermetures de classes
qui vont se poursuivre en raison du
déclin de notre démographie scolaire
c'est le seul moyen de faire accepter
par les parents d'élèves et les élèves
ces fermetures qui si elles sont
justifiées ne sont pas toujours bien
accepté
le besoin ensuite de répondre un
paradoxe
l'augmentation significative du nombre
de métiers en tension d'une part et
d'autre part le nombre encore important
d'orientation inadaptés de nos jeunes
alors ma question monsieur le ministre
portera sur ce dernier point comment
répondre à ce paradoxe et s'assurer que
les ministères de l'éducation nationale
oriente mieux nos jeunes compatriotes
merci monsieur le député pour les
écologistes nubes francesca parce qu ni
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues il ya encore
quelques semaines j'enseigne à une
classe de ce1 aujourd'hui avec beaucoup
d sion je souhaite dénoncer les
conditions salariales des enseignants en
1981 il gagnait 2,3 fois le smic
aujourd'hui une ville dans une ou deux
fois seulement gel du point d'indicé pas
de prime pas de 13e mois le cd e classe
la france parmi les pays de l'union
européenne qui payent le moins bien ces
enseignants derrière l'italie et devant
la pologne deux fois moins bien payés
qu'en allemagne cette baisse du pouvoir
d'achat s'accompagne de conditions
d'exercice de fonction qui se dégradent
méprise et sous payés et pourtant
toujours en première ligne prêt à
s'adapter pour assurer la continuité
éducative en tant que député dans cette
commission je souhaite porter plusieurs
projets mais aucun ne pourra s'appliquer
sans des enseignants dans les classes et
aujourd'hui le métier n'attire plus les
démissions flambent et on organise des
speed dating pour embaucher il ya des
collègues qui sont à découvert dès le
début du mois malgré cela ils exercent
leur métier avec coeur ne laissant rien
transparaître devant les élèves un
exemple parmi d'autres quand je suis
arrivé à l'assemblée on m'a fourni un
bel ordinateur il vaut autant que celui
qui était mon salaire enseignante j'ai
bénéficié de la prime équipements 150
euros nets par an ce qui signifie qu'il
m'aurait fallu environ 12 ans de primes
pour acheter cet ordinateur dans ces
conditions on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
blâmer ceux qui partent ni motiver des
nouvelles recrues heureusement les
enseignants sont des passionnés il
continue allumé des feux alors que leur
coupe est pleine nous pouvons être à
l'origine du plus ambitieux des
programmes pour l'école encore faut-il
des enseignants pour le mettre en oeuvre
monsieur le ministre nous sommes au
début de notre mandat vous venez d'être
nommé à ce poste très prestigieux
je viens d'être élu député j'ose espérer
que dans cinq ans nous aurons redonner
ses lettres de noblesse à cette
profession indispensable
très concrètement quelles sont les
mesures que vous envisagez pour
augmenter le salaire des enseignants et
pas seulement pour les nouveaux
collègues merci merci madame la députée
pour le groupe gdr nubes stéphane peu
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre votre audition
était
attendu car vous ne pouvez pas ignorer
que les cinq dernières années ont été
marquées par une dégradation importante
du dialogue entre votre ministère ce
ministère et la communauté éducative
vous le savez pour les parents d'élèves
et pour les familles populaires en
particulier l'école et pour ses enfants
une immense source d'espérance et une
promesse républicaine au plein sens du
terme malheureusement l'école est de
moins en moins un creuset d'émancipation
et de promotion sociale mais de plus en
plus une machine à reproduire les
inégalités sociales si j'ajoute à cela
le drôle de principes républicains qui
fait que dans les départements
populaires comme le mien celui de la
seine-saint-denis on donne moins à ceux
qui ont moins parce que c'est ça
aujourd'hui la réalité de l'école
publique comme un rapport parlementaire
qu'elle fait l'unanimité de ses bancs
l'a démontré alors on pourrait dire
beaucoup de choses mais je voudrais vous
interroger sur l'urgence des urgences
celle de la rentrée scolaire qui
s'annonce nous nous attendions au regard
de l'ensemble des difficultés qui
s'amoncellent à l'horizon de la rentrée
scolaire à ce qu'il y ait au moins des
choses dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui tourne nous permettent
au moins de pallier dans l'urgence un
situation critique qui s'annonce il y
avait rien dans la loi de finances
rectificative et vous avez pris
l'engagement qu'il y aurait un
enseignant devant chaque classe à la
rentrée on veut bien vous croire ces
promesses ont déjà été fait mais nous
avons pu constater en scène sont menées
en particulier que si à la rentrée
scolaire il y avait un enseignant devant
chaque classe 15 jours après dès le
début du mois d'octobre ce n'était plus
le cas parce que tous les enseignants
parmi ceux là ceux qui avaient été
recrutés par le bon coin qui pour
certains étaient même pas francophone
donc ne pouvait pas faire classe avait
quitté l'école dans les quinze jours qui
avaient suivi la rentrée donc la
question n'est pas la rentrée scolaire
la question elle est comment assurer un
enseignant devant chaque classe pendant
toute la durée de lascaux ii de l'année
qui s'annonce merci monsieur le député
la parole à stéphane le normand pour le
groupe iott
monsieur peu
merci voilà je recommence alors ma
présidence je me dis je voulais vous
êtes à reculer sur sur deux
problématiques au nom de membres ou la
première concerne la formation continue
des enseignants dans les outre-mer alors
c'est un sujet qui avait déjà été
évoquée par le sénat en 2020 qui avait
demandé à la cour des comptes de
réaliser une enquête portant sur les
systèmes éducatifs des académies
d'outre-mer et force est de constater
que l'état des lieux dressé par cette
même cour concernant la formation
continue des enseignants et le
remplacement de ces derniers n'est pas
satisfaisant pour plusieurs raisons au
point que celle-ci a recommandé
d'accroître l'effort de formation
continue en construisant des plans de
formation des enseignants adaptés aux
besoins et qui tienne compte
naturellement des contraintes locales
notamment d'éloignement et de transport
alors j'aimerais savoir monsieur le
ministre quel est votre analyse sur
cette problématique a quel sens les
moyens et objectifs que vous comptiez m
pour y remédier le deuxième sujet
concerne l'école inclusive le nombre
d'élèves en situation de handicap
accueilli en milieu ordinaire ne cesse
de croître il dépasse en 2021 les 400000
ce qui représente une hausse de 25%
depuis 2010 est le nombre
d'accompagnements des élèves en
situation de handicap les arrêts sachent
qu'ils sont importants a lui aussi
augmenté de 33% sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat toutefois il s'avère que
l'ensemble des notifications des maisons
départementales pour la personne
handicapée les mdph ne peuvent
malheureusement malheureusement ne pas
être satisfaite alors naturellement les
conditions d'emploi des années sache ne
sont pas non plus satisfaisantes même
s'il ya des évolutions dernièrement qui
vont dans ce sens et vous avez indiqué
monsieur le ministre vouloir que de
véritable carrière driver sache se
dessine alors je voudrais savoir si vous
pouvez nous préciser ces éléments quand
on vous comptez avancer sur ce chantier
de l'école inclusive et notamment sur
les conditions de recrutement et
d'emploi des années je préconise la
scolarité des élèves en situation de
handicap se fasse dans les meilleures
conditions merci merci monsieur le
député de la parole maintenant et à vous
monsieur le ministre pour la réponse
mais en tout cas je tenais à remercier
mes collègues d'avoir bien voulu
respecter des temps de parole merci
merci mesdames et messieurs les députés
ces questions sont toutes essentielles
elles des thèmes reviennent reviennent à
travers vos différentes interventions et
en premier lieu de façon très évidente
la question de la crise de recrutement
et celle de l'attractivité des métiers
de l'enseignement cette question était
présente pratiquement dans toutes vos
interventions et vous avez raison je ne
veux pas et je ne vais pas nier la
réalité qui est celle d'une grave crise
de recrutement et d'une grave crise
d'attractivité ce qu'on appelle la la
rentabilité des concours est faible on
est aux alentours de 2 83% pour la
rentabilité des concours du second degré
et on a du mal à recruter en effet dans
beaucoup de disciplines et également
dans le premier degré pour ce qui
concerne les académies francilienne donc
nous avons une situation qui est une
situation
structurellement dégradé je dirais ça
n'est pas que deux cette année mais qui
est accrue en quelque sorte cette année
par le phénomène conjoncturel que j'ai
souligné précédemment c'est à dire le
passage du concours du m1 ou m2 qui a
tari le vivier on est par exemple pour
vous donner une idée on est aux
alentours de 18 mille candidats pour le
capes pour les capes donc des concours
du second degré l'année dernière on
avait trente mille candidats et pour
bien faire il en faudrait 50 milles
voilà pour vous donner une idée générale
de la situation et donc il faut
reconnaître nos difficultés pour pallier
ou pour
faire face à ces difficultés on ne va
pas le faire en trois semaines d'ici au
1er septembre et donc est en effet au
1er septembre
nous avons recours à un volant
d'enseignants contractuels
plus important que ce que nous
souhaiterions c'est indéniable en
réfléchissant et en prévoyant des
mesures plus structurelles je m'empresse
de préciser que ce volant d'enseignants
le contractuel à l'échelle du pays
demeure relativement
raisonnable on parle d'environ 1 %
d'enseignants contractuels dans le
premier degré est d'environ 8 %
second degré avec des variations
importantes il faut le reconnaître selon
les départements et selon les académies
il y a des départements par exemple
celui de la seine saint denis monsieur
le député ou bien des départements comme
celui de la guyane ou de mayotte où le
pourcentage d'enseignants contractuels
est nettement plus élevé que ce que je
viens d'indiquer mais nous devons avoir
recours à des enseignants contractuels
nous avons également recours aux listes
complémentaires pour ce qui concerne les
concours nationaux c'est-à-dire les
concours du second degré nous avons dans
beaucoup de disciplines vider les listes
complémentaires c'est le cas par exemple
dans une discipline que je connais bien
l'histoire l'agrégation d'histoire le
capes
d'histoire géographie nous avons vidé
les listes complémentaires en donnant
toute latitude au jury pour ce faire
c'est au jury ce n'est pas à moi de
d'estimé jusqu'où on va dans la liste
complémentaire cela se fait en fonction
des notes cela se fait en fonction du
niveau des comptes pour mais nous avons
été dans cette direction pour ce qui
concerne les concours académique c'est à
dire le concours de professeur des
écoles c'est un recrutement académique
et donc quand il y a une liste
complémentaire en bretagne par exemple
on ne peut pas vider entre guillemets
cette liste complémentaire et affecter
les enseignants concernés dans
l'académie de versailles ou de créteil
cela ne peut pas se faire compte tenu du
caractère régional de ces concours mais
nous proposons néanmoins en particulier
au lauréat ou enfin home liste
complémentaire qui sont dans les
académies à proximité de l'île de france
reims rouen amiens de venir enseigner à
c'est donc à ces personnes de venir
enseigner du côté de versailles ou du
côté de créteil mais cela n'est pas une
proposition particulièrement attirante
en tout cas cela ne résout pas de façon
structurelle nos difficultés de
recrutement donc nous faisons avec la
situation qui est la nôtre qui est une
situation de difficulté de recrutement
je suis tout à fait conscient monsieur
ou madame le député pardonnez moi je ne
sais plus qui me posait la question des
difficultés dans l'année le banc de
touche est très réduit si je puis
utiliser cette expression ça j'en suis
également tout à fait conscients
les job dating je crois que madame la
députée vous avez fait allusion à cela
en réalité quand on se penche sur les
processus de recrutement des enseignants
contractuels ces processus là ne sont ne
se règle pas en quelques minutes entre
deux portes il y aura tout un processus
qui consiste à regarder les dossiers à
centre il ya un entretien voir plusieurs
entretiens qu on ne peut pas
expression a été lancé et je la récuse
résumé sous la forme d'un job dating ou
de quelque chose qui se passerait de
façon très rapide mais enfin nous avons
recours à des enseignants contractuels
c'est absolument évident et
particulièrement pour cette rentrée
maintenant il faut réfléchir sur le long
terme réfléchir sur le long terme ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire revaloriser
le métier c'est pourquoi j'ai parlé de
choc d'attractivité en ce qui concerne
la rémunération des enseignants en effet
une rémunération au niveau que vous avez
indiquée n'est pas une rémunération
acceptable est satisfaisante en début de
carrière quand on a un bac + 5 il ne
faut pas s'étonner quand on est à bac +
quand on recrute à bac + 5 à 1 au niveau
de salaire que l'on propose alors il ya
toujours les engagements personnels bien
entendu qui compte beaucoup dans ce
métier mais enfin ses engagements
personnels pour le métier ne suffisent
pas face à des salaires qui sont
notoirement insuffisants la hausse de
rémunération que nous sommes en
élaboration avec en discussion et un
échange avec le ministère des comptes
publics
cette hausse de rémunération concerne
les débuts de carrière mais elle doit
aussi permettre de retravailler
l'évolution des salaires puisque
actuellement nous avons un allié une
hausse de salaire initial et ensuite un
palier une sorte de faux plat si vous
voulez très long pendant lequel les
enseignants ne voient pas leur
rémunération augmenter et donc là aussi
on a une difficulté c'est l'ensemble de
cette grille salariale qu'il faut
repenser à l'exception des dernières
années où là il ya un rattrapage qui se
fait en particulier avec le passage en
hors classe mais pour le reste on est
dans une situation qui est objectivement
une situation difficile et nous devons
donc travailler sur les salaires ça
j'insiste beaucoup sur ce point et j'ai
je me suis engagé d'ailleurs sur des
salaires qui ne doivent pas être un et
rieur à 2000 euros en début de carrière
je le dis et je le répète ensuite la
cette question du métier ou de l'arrêt
valorisation du métier ne tient pas
seulement à à des niveaux de salaires il
tient aussi à la carrière la carrière
des enseignants à la historiquement été
pensé comme une carrière longue on entre
dans le métier vers 25 ans et on en sort
à la retraite or aujourd'hui on observe
que les itinéraires sont des itinéraires
plus variés avec des deuxièmes carrière
on entre dans le métier vers 40 ans par
exemple après avoir fait déjà une
carrière dans un autre secteur une
proposition était faite sur la prise en
compte de ses débuts de carrière c'est
important il ya aussi la question de la
mobilité à 40 45 ans on n'est pas aussi
mobile qu'à 25 ans et donc être affectés
à l'autre bout du pays c'est parfois
extrêmement difficile et on a des cas de
démissions d'enseignants du sud de la
france qui sont affectés en région
parisienne où ailleurs dans le pays donc
il faut réfléchir sur ces questions il
faut réfléchir à des portes de sortie la
possibilité au bout de 10 ans ou quinze
ans de faire autre chose éventuellement
de revenir dans l'enseignement après il
ya des questions qui sont des questions
assez classiquement rh
des questions à penser compte tenu des
aspirations de notre jeunesse en
particulier qui ne sont plus aussi
linéaire du point de vue des carrières
c'est vrai dans l'enseignement mais
c'est vrai également dans beaucoup
d'autres métiers il faut absolument
qu'on soit beaucoup plus mobile là
dessus et que les propositions que nous
faisons s'adapte à des itinéraires
professionnels et les itinéraires de vie
qui ont changé et auquel nous devons
être attentifs il y a aussi d'autres
questions qui se posent sur
l'attractivité du métier les études à
l'échelle européenne suggère par exemple
que un facteur d'attractivité important
c'est le fait de travailler en équipe
c'est de ne pas y tous dans sa classe si
je puis dire en tout cas en face à face
et puis de ne croiser les collègues que
le matin ou à l'occasion de la pause
café en allemagne par exemple où les
salaires sont deux fois plus élevés
qu'en france a priori le la question
n'est pas une question de salaire et
pourtant il y a un problème
d'attractivité du métier en allemagne on
a du mal à recruter c'est pas une
question de salaire donc on voit bien
qu'il ya d'autres questions qui se
posent qui ne se règle pas simplement
par le niveau de rémunération mais aussi
par les modalités de travail par le
travail ensemble par le travail en
équipe par les questions de carrière que
j'ai évoqués précédemment et c'est tout
cela que nous voulons discuter cet
automne avec les organisations
représentatives bien entendu avec les
partenaires qui sont nos partenaires
afin de proposer des carrières afin de
proposer des rémunérations qui soit
attractive pour nos enseignants enfin je
veux mentionner aussi au passage une
réflexion que nous devons entamer sur le
recrutement et il est il absolument
nécessaire et est ce une bonne idée que
de recruter des professeurs des écoles à
bac + 5 par exemple voilà une question
que l'on peut se poser la masterisation
c'est un fait c'est acquis mais là le
recrutement à bac + 5 qui est de
surcroît injuste socialement puisqu'il
faut pouvoir mener des études jusqu'à
bac + 5 alors que le professorat des
écoles représentait une possibilités
d'ascension sociale pour celles et ceux
qui étaient issus des mondes populaire
voilà une question que nous voulons
aussi posé et discuter bref c'est un une
nous entendons et nous avons l'ambition
de
reposer de façon très très large le
métier de professeur bien au delà de la
question de la rémunération mais vous
concevez que cela ne veut pas se faire
en l'espace d'un été et donc en
attendant nous avons en effet recours à
des enseignants contractuels que nous
suivons que nous mentent auront que nous
formons aussi bien que possible mais ça
n'est pas une situation idéale
je suis en accord avec vous
pardon d'avoir été un peu long sur le
sujet madame la présidente mais il me
semblait que compte tenu de l'importance
de cette question elle méritait que je
m'y arrête un peu ensuite la question
des deux qui a été posée notamment par
monsieur le député judo qui est la
question des des du contenu des réformes
de ce qui est en jeu là je voudrais
faire de remarques à ce sujet la
première c'est que le les années qui ont
précédé avec jean michel blanquer mon
prédécesseur ont été marqués par des
réformes de grande ampleur
particulièrement dans
dans le premier degré et du côté des
lycées avec la réforme du lycée et puis
la réforme du bac or ces réformes du
point de vue de leurs évaluations ont
été très impacté par la crise sanitaire
de telle sorte que si l'on prend le cas
de la réforme du lycée et de la réforme
du bac y compris pour les jeunes qui
viennent de passer le bac dans des
conditions à peu près normale mais
considérons que ces jeunes ont été en
seconde et en première en plein dans la
crise sanitaire et donc leur itinéraire
de lycée n'a pas été un itinéraire
normal il a été très impacté par le
confinement et part d une relation à
l'école ou au lycée qui a été
détérioré même si la france a fait
beaucoup mieux que d'autres pays en la
matière et donc nous avons besoin
d'évaluations et nous n'avons pas
d'évaluation
solide encore sur la réforme du lycée je
dirais envisagé dans sa dimension
ordinaire en période ordinaire orco vide
ce que nous faisons et c'est la grande
vertu de cette réforme du lycée c'est
qu'elle est perfectible c'est à dire
qu'on peut la retoucher
peut l'améliorer on peut voir
pragmatiquement ce qui marche bien ce
qui marche moins bien
c'est ce que nous avons fait d'ailleurs
en réintroduisant l'heure et demie de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun des
classes de première et donc nous sommes
très attentifs mais je ne vais pas nous
n'allons pas nous lancer dans une énième
grande réforme du lycée sans même avoir
d'évaluation précises et sérieuse de ce
qui se vit de ce qui vient d'être fait
et à mon sens justement fait y compris
d'ailleurs pour parcours super car je
veux bien que l'on critique parcours sup
mais quelle était la situation apb la
situation avant parcours sup avec une
course vers les portes des universités
pour s'inscrire quand ce n'étaient pas
des tirages au sort dans certaines
filières en tension je n'ai aucune
nostalgie pour cette époque là parcours
sup à des
perfectible s'améliore d'année en année
et meuse et et nécessitent d'être
évalués de façon juste avec là encore ce
potentiel perfectible que je soulignais
à l'instant
le deuxième élément que je voulais
souligner par rapport à allah aux
perspectives de réformes c'est qu'il
faut se tenir compte de la fatigue ça a
été aussi une de mes grandes
je ne dirais pas surprise mais en tout
cas une une remarque qui m'a frappé et
un état qui m'a frappé en arrivant à la
tête de ce ministère c'est l'état de
fatigue des enseignants du monde
éducatif en général
fatigué par la crise sanitaire par les
efforts qui ont été consentis et si
justement consenti ge je salue au
passage ses efforts remarquables des
équipes enseignantes
administratives et de direction mais
aussi les fatigues et les tensions
générées par les réformes qui suscite
toujours des remises en cause des
interrogations des questionnements et
donc je ne souhaite pas précipiter à
nouveau le lycée où le premier cycle
dans un cycle nouveau de réformes sans
évaluation précise et sérieuse de la
situation et sans tenir compte de l'état
des troupes nous
nous avons enfin tout de même une
question est là le point était soulignée
par deux d'entre vous qui est celle du
collège en effet le collège est pris en
sandwich entre le premier cycle et le
lycée et donc nous sommes
nous penchons et nous travaillons sur la
question du collège qu'ils méritent en
effet une attention
particulière sur pardon encore un point
peut-être je voulais que mes collègues
fasse un tout petit peu moins de bruit
pour qu'on puisse bien vous entendre
je mets
beaucoup de nos collègues sont faits le
président letton qui on est et là vous
êtes en train de répondre par avance à
toutes les questions qui se posent donc
d'accord alors je vais
chez moi je me suis fait de ces de ces
exercices mais le professeur que je suis
a tendance à être un peu bavard parfois
là je jeunes oublient qu aucun des
points que vous avez signalé je je je
voudrais néanmoins
[Musique]
m'arrêter un instant sur un point qui
est qui est important et qui est revient
de manière récurrente c'est celui de
l'école inclusive et des avs h et en
effet
pardon je crois que c'est vous monsieur
le député qui avait hier adacore annonce
la question la question a été posée la
question posée par madame mettent
d'accord alors je benhamadi pardon vous
souhaitez que je là que je la garde en
réserve non alesi et puis
alors vous avez en effet souligné la
progression remarquable des élèves de
l'inclusion des élèves à besoins
particuliers dans les écoles ordinaires
avec une progression qui nous fait
dépasser les 410 mille élèves
aujourd'hui et c'est une réussite
remarquable de notre système éducatif
que je tiens vraiment à saluer on ne
peut que se féliciter que de l'inclusion
de ces élèves ensuite
ensuite il faut se pencher sur une autre
question qui est celle des abbesses h
dans la croissance a été très importante
on est à 122 me lâche on en recrute 4000
nouveau à la rentrée après en avoir
recruter 4000 à la rentrée
2021 c'est un message en effet il ya des
questions qui sont liées à leur temps de
travail 24 heures pour beaucoup de temps
de travail ça ne fait pas un salaire
suffisant à la fin du mois le président
de la république a parlé et s'est engagé
à ce qu'on aille vers les 35 heures pour
les avs âge ce qui implique de prendre
en considération le périscolaire et
notamment la pause méridienne or vous
connaissez l'arrêt du conseil d'état
celui de novembre 2020 qui enjoint à
l'état de nous rémunérer les avais sache
que sur le temps scolaire et pas sur le
temps périscolaire et donc nous sommes
nous avons cette difficulté qui à la
fois qu à la fois juridique et
administrative qui consiste à ce que les
abbés ça soit à la fois rémunérés par
les temps et par les collectivités
territoriales
particulièrement les avais sage qui
s'occupe d'enfants qui ont besoin d'une
grande continuité dans leur suivi dans
la journée c'est le cas notamment des
enfants qui présentent des troubles
autistiques 11% du total de nos enfants
en question des 410 mille présentent des
troubles autistiques ce qui réclame une
attention tout à fait particulière et
puis il y a aussi des questions qui sont
liées aux mdph et au nifff aux
notifications de messages qui sont
faites par les mdph les mdph ne
dépendent évidemment pas du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
et donc à une réflexion à mener aussi
sur le fait de savoir si la meilleure
solution possible est toujours celle de
l' os h ça n'est pas forcément le cas
une réponse a été amorcé avec la
création des piale à l'échelle 10 ont
départementales ou à l'échelle locale
mais il nous faut aller plus loin pour
imaginer une diversité de réponse aux
besoins prioritaires qui sont ceux de
nos enfants et de l'accroissement du
nombre d'enfants à besoins particuliers
dans les écoles ordinaires ce qui est
par ailleurs une excellente chose donc
la question d adressage est en effet
posée celle de leur recrutement celle de
leurs conditions de travail celle aussi
de leur cd isation si vous me permettez
l'expression
vingt mille ash son cd lisez avec une
grille de carrière et avec une
progression de carrière que nous devons
également penser avec aussi de la
formation continue pour cae sage qui
sont à 95% je ne dois pas me tromper des
femmes je souligne aussi la dimension
très genre et du métier de s h qui est
aussi une des questions qui se posent
quand on réfléchit là dessus donc nous
nous sommes au travail pour sécuriser
les carrières des usa h pour répondre
aux besoins de l'école inclusive qui est
de toute façon une priorité
merci monsieur de ministres déjà pour
toutes ces réponses donc maintenant nous
allons prendre une dizaine de questions
nous allons commencer avec céline
calvaise pour une minute
merci madame la présidente je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre d'avoir
rappelé de manière très claire à votre
introduction quels étaient les cinq axes
qui visait votre feuille de route
pendant la campagne des élections
présidentielles emmanuel macron avait
proposé une démarche d'associations des
parties prenantes dans la défis sont
immenses et il est talent tous
indispensables et l'un de ses chantiers
il sait bien l'éducation et vous l'avez
annoncé la concertation des parties
prenantes commencera fin septembre et
vous venez de vérifier les contours de
cette démarche un un débat à l'échelle
de chaque école vous appelez de vos
voeux des centaines voire des milliers
de débats j'espère qu'ils seront
nombreux dans l'ensemble de notre
circonscription comme dans la mienne à
clichy levallois
2,7 ces débats devrait associer toute la
communauté éducative pouvez vous nous
indiquez votre acceptions de la
communauté éducative
j'espère qu'elle sera aussi large que
celle utilisée dans les cité éducative
alors ces débats démocratiques
pourront-ils ainsi associer les
collectivités les acteurs associatifs et
économiques
troisièmement c'est un débat dans chaque
école qui dépasse le diagnostic mais
pourra aussi aboutir à des propositions
vous avez précisé que certaines d'entre
elles pourront se voir financer par
l'éducation nationale comment les
sélectionner les évaluer enfin dans ce
débat démocratique
quelle place pour nous les
parlementaires si c'est un enjeu
national avec la place pour nous la
représentation nationale merci madame la
députée annie genevard
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué la question
des savoirs fondamentaux et de leur
maîtrise par les élèves les comparaisons
internationales montrent que la france
accorde
comparativement plus d'heures aux
savoirs fondamentaux que
que d'autres pays européens la france et
accorde beaucoup de temps et pourtant
les résultats ne sont pas au rendez vous
c'est ce que vous nous avez dit
moi je crois que c'est une question
fondamentale
il faut pouvoir se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi alors même que nous
consacrons du temps et des moyens à
l'acquisition des savoirs fondamentaux
ceux ci ne sont pas correctement acquis
et on sait que sa forme des bataillons
d'élèves vouée à l'échec scolaire
votre prédécesseur s'était ému
évidemment de cette question et nous
avions fait les proposer sur la matière
nous avions proposé le tutorat par des
enseignants retraités chevronnés cela
nous a été refusé
vous avions proposé la vérification des
méthodes d'enseignement cela nous a été
refusé
quelle est votre réponse à cette
question que je crois très amer je suis
madame la députée la parole et à st paul
est
merci madame la présidente monsieur deux
ministres lors de son hommage à samuel
pâtit le président de la république a
cité un extrait d'un discours de
ferdinand buisson qui a affirmé je cite
que le premier devoir d'une république
et de faire des républicains la
république est en effet toujours en
construction elle n'est pas un processus
achevé
de même la liberté l'esprit critique
l'émancipation ne sont pas innées mais
des conquêtes qui repose en grande
partie sur l'instruction et donc sur
l'école aujourd'hui l'éducation civique
ne dit rien de la république elle est
devenue une discipline technique la
laïcité et sa jumelle la citoyenneté ne
représente plus grand chose pour une
partie des élèves mais aussi des
professeurs notre nation est déchiré et
tient de plus en plus d'un archipel d'un
agrégat de communauté qui pensent que
l'addition de leurs revendications est à
même de définir l'intérêt général
comment le chantier de la refondation de
l'école peut-il contribuer à refaire des
républicains je vous remercie monsieur
merci madame la députée la parole et à
anne sophie frigo
le microsite
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre le 25 juin dernier vous avez
affirmé qu'il y aurait un professeur
devant chaque classe à la rentrée à moi
vous soyez prêt à tous les sacrifices y
compris fermé de nombreuses classes
cette promesse s'annonce déjà comme
caduc si votre annonce d'augmentation
des salaires des enseignants est
bienvenue elle ne suffira pas à réduire
la crise de la vocation et la vague de
démissions et ce n'est pas un usage de
plus en plus fréquent de la
contractualisation et l'organisation de
job dating qui régleront ce problème car
vous recrutez en 15 minutes des
personnes qui n'ont pas été formés pour
enseigner comme si ce métier pouvait
apprendre sur le tas
quel mépris pour les enseignants qui ont
travaillé dur pour valider un master et
réussir le concours du capes pour
pouvoir assurer le dédoublement des
classes de cp ce1 dans de nombreux
quartiers le gouvernement formé beaucoup
de classe dans la ruralité ce qui est
inacceptable qu'un vous compromettez
ainsi l'égalité des chances des élèves
déjà bien abîmée par niveau scolaire en
chute libre dans votre gouvernement n'a
pour l'heure trouvé aucune solution et
risquent de se retrouver à cannes et à
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
confirmer que vous encouragerez plus le
recours à la contractualisation et
hushovd est il si madame la députée
qu'ils ont la vocation la parole et à
béatrice piron pour une minute
merci mme la présidente
lesieu le ministre à l'hôtesse de
fluence qui évalue la fluidité de
lecture démontrent que bien trop
d'élèves de 6e n'ont pas niveaux de
lecture attendu au collège ce test à
paris a fait apparaître qu'un tiers des
élèves de 6e ont un niveau qui relève du
ce2 et bien plus est préoccupant qu
environ 15% des élèves ne savent pas
encore lire correctement j'ai été
pendant cinq ans président du groupe
d'études illettrisme et le renforcement
de l'apprentissage de la lecture ne
tient particulièrement encore car cette
indispensable pour progresser en matière
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
mais aussi en matière d'égalité des
chances de nombreux efforts ont déjà été
réalisées puis 2018 en rêve il ré plus
notamment grâce aux dédoublements de
classe néamoins 80% des élèves ne sont
pas scolarisés en zone prioritaire
votre prédécesseur avait fait part de sa
volonté de prendre de nouvelles
initiatives pour que la classe de 6e
fassent l'objet de renforcement lecture
mais vous monsieur le ministre que
proposez vous de faire pour ces
collégiens en grande souffrance enfin
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard pour la
scolarité
merci madame la députée la parole est à
mme jérome le grave
oui monsieur ministre l'enseignement
professionnel a été instituée après la
guerre pour soustraire la jeunesse à la
tutelle des patrons la décision qui a
été prise par ce gouvernement de placer
l'enseignement professionnel sous la
double tutelle de l'éducation nationale
et du ministère du travail représente un
recul historique des plus inquiétants
vous voulez le rapprochement de
l'enseignement professionnel et de
l'apprentissage et on connaît l'objectif
fixé d'un million d'apprentis qui permet
aux entreprises d'utiliser une main
d'oeuvre bon marché qui met en cause les
qualifications gros problèmes sur les
sept cent dix mille contrats
d'apprentissage en 2021 37 % concernent
des formations de l'enseignement
secondaire infra bac donc dès lors
comment obtenir l'objectif réaliser sans
vider littéralement les lycées
professionnels de leurs élèves ni
laissant que des jeunes en très grande
difficulté je rappelle qu'en trente ans
562 lycée professionnel ont fermé ou ont
été sérieusement amputé de leur section
en ce moment même dans le département de
dans l'académie de créteil pardonnez-moi
2000 jeunes sortant de troisième sont en
attente d'affectation d'un lycée
professionnel vous comprendrez donc mis
moins je l'espère notre extrême inquiet
du maire ça l'avenir de l'enseignement
professionnel et avis la parole est à
béatrice bellamy
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre notre école est le bien le plus
précieux de la nation elle est bien
souvent dans de nombreuses communes
notamment rurales le service public de
proximité
voire unique une classe une école c'est
un coeur battant d'une commune je sais
la difficulté de gestion de la carte
scolaire et la délicate mission des
dizaines mais je m'interroge mesure je
vous interroge sur la fermeture des
classes sid et parfois avec une
légitimité fragile c'est le cas dans ma
circonscription
une classe est annoncé fermer courant
juin et à un ou deux élèves reprennent
sans prendre en compte les inscriptions
qui suivent sans prendre en compte les
réfugiés ukrainiens sont prendre en
compte l'ouverture d'un compte centre
pardon de gens du voyage sans prendre en
compte la dynamique démographique ni les
projets immobiliers à long terme ce
cadre rigide et seulement comptable ne
me semble plus adapté aux réalités notre
temps lui met en tension et en sursis
permanent les enseignants les parents
d'élèves et le bien-être des élèves il
n'est bien souvent de côté les locaux
pensez vous monsieur le ministre au
revoir le système actuel de révision de
la carte scolaire pour plus de
pragmatisme et d'assurance à long terme
pour fonder cette réflexion sur les
réalités et les cohérences de termes
merci madame la députée la parole est à
julien haut doubs là
il faut que tu étais le micro
merci mme la présidente monsieur le
ministre après l'effroyable attentats
islamistes contre samuel pâtit le 16
octobre 2020 qu'est ce qui a changé pour
l'enseignement l'affirmation de nos
valeurs et aux principes républicains au
sein de l'école au premier rang desquels
la liberté d'expression et la laïcité
votre prédécesseur monsieur blanc caire
évoqué un avant et un après samuel pâti
dans les faits il n'en est rien pour le
premier trimestre 2011 22 votre
ministère a dénombré 627 signalement
pour atteinte à la laïcité c'est une
explosion puisque depuis décembre 2020
une augmentation de que de 14% donc je
voulais vous demander monsieur le
ministre qu est ce que vous envisagez
pour préserver nos valeurs pour les
affirmer au sein de l'école pour
protéger aussi nos professeurs qui sont
confrontés à l'intolérance à la haine et
à des menaces pour protéger nos
professeurs qui sont empêchés
d'enseignés que ce soit la shoah que ce
soit les caricatures de mahomet que ce
soit l'évolution de l'homme ses
principes et ses enseignements
essentiels
donc monsieur le ministre est ce que la
liberté d'expression des laïcités figure
toujours au programme de l'éducation
nationale merci monsieur le député la
parole est à graziella melchior merci
madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre d'après le bilan
social de l'éducation nationale le
nombre d'inscrits au concours de
l'enseignement du second degré est passé
de 50 mille candidats présents en 2008 à
30 milles en 2020 soit une diminution de
plus de 30%
pour pallier le manque d'enseignants
l'éducation nationale a recours à des
contractuels de l'eau nombre a augmenté
de 47% selon une note de la direction de
la prospective 2020 j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que ce statut est
parfois le résultat d'un choix pour
échapper à l'inconfort de certaines
mutations en effet des enseignants
peuvent se retrouver éloignés de leur
famille ou se voir refuser des postes
cela peut être encore plus difficile à
vivre dans des contextes de médicaux ou
familiaux particulier comme j'en ai à
connaître dans ma circonscription du
finistère
pour ces motifs des candidats au métier
d'enseignant voir des enseignants en
poste valeurs préférées un contrat au
concours aussi monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais savoir c'est une gestion plus
humaines du système des mutations serait
possible afin de ne pas freiner la
volonté d'engagement de nos futurs
enseignants je vous remercie madame la
députée la parole et à iñaki et chinese
merci même à la prison monsieur le
ministre en france les langues dites
régionales ne bénéficient pas de la
protection et de l'encouragement de
l'état dans leur utilisation et leur
parcours d'apprentissage
l'actualité l'actualité récente est
illustrative de cet état de fait la loi
mulak censurée en partie par le conseil
constitutionnel à la demande de la
majorité
la réorganisation de l'enseignement
secondaire et du bac responsable d'une
baisse des effectifs le refus de
corriger les épreuves passées en langue
régionale pénalisant les élèves des
filières bilingues et immersive
l'expérience nous mentionne qu'il faut
sécuriser ce type d'enseignement d'un
point de vue légal en ratifiant la
charte européenne des langues
minoritaires en votant un texte
reprenant un circulaire de décembre 2
décembre 2021 et précisant les modalités
d'examens et ensuite en encourageant
dans les parcours scolaires une offre
pourvu d'une dotation spécifique l'état
de faiblesse dans lequel se trouvent les
langues régionales qui sont pourtant une
richesse de nos territoires de notre
pays réaliser une politique urgente et
volontaire dead de soutien et de
développement de ces langues alors
monsieur le ministre quel est votre
position est votre ambition politique
pour le développement des langues
régionales quelle est votre position sur
le passage des examens en langue
régionale et quelle est votre position
sur le développement et la mise en
valeur de cette richesse nationale
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
vous monsieur le ministre pour des
réponses courtes conceive et précise
merci se rappelle madame la présidente
je vais commencer par les les débats
la députée
que votre question soulevée ces débats
dans les écoles l'idée donc notre projet
c'est de faire cela en plusieurs avec
plusieurs étapes une étape qui est celle
des débats qui auront lieu dans les
haies dans les écoles et les
établissements scolaires au mois
d'octobre une deuxième étape portera sur
les établissements qui souhaiteront
aller plus loin que le débat ait formulé
un projet qui peut s'appuyer d'ailleurs
sur le projet d'établissement existants
afin que en dans le premier trimestre
2011 23 nous puissions
selon un bon équilibre académique que
cela soit le cas dans toutes les régions
sélectionner les projets qui feront
l'objet d'un premier financement et de
ce point de vue là il me semblerait tout
à fait utile que les élus locaux mais
aussi des parlementaires des députés par
exemple puisse être partie prenante de
ces débats y compris du côté des jurys
et des processus de sélection que nous
mettrons en place en 2023 je serai très
désireux que la représentation nationale
soit associée et puis c'est également
aussi prendre connaissance des projets
de ce qui sera élaboré dans les
établissements du côté des savoirs
fondamentaux madame la députée je
partage évidemment le point que vous
soulignez et j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
que ça n'est pas en ajoutant de façon
quantitative des heures de maths et de
français que l'on résout quelque sorte
automatiquement ou mécaniquement les
difficultés que nous connaissons et donc
nous devons nous pencher sur aussi sur
les méthodes pédagogiques sur le contenu
nous sommes un peu au milieu du guet
finalement puisque les réformes qui ont
été engagées du côté des mathématiques
et du français
dans les écoles
élémentaires que ces efforts là ne sont
pas encore complètement évaluer on va le
l'évaluer d'ailleurs avec l'évaluation
de 6e qui va venir mais nous avons quand
même
lieu de croire que nous enregistrons des
progrès nous allons voir de quelle
manière comment on peut avancer j'ai
bien retenu les propositions que vous
avez fait et je serais heureux
évidemment d'échanger avec vous mais
nous sommes encore en phase d'évaluation
mais je videmment le votre point de
départ est évidemment je suis en accord
avec ce point de départ sur le fait de
refaire des républicains madame la
députée jeu évidemment je partage votre
votre souci est en vous écoutant je
pensais au projet qui était celui de
jules ferry et de ferdinand buisson à la
fin du 19e siècle il s'agissait d'un
projet d'instruction publique c'était
d'ailleurs le nom de ce ministère mais
c'était aussi un projet républicain
c'était aussi un projet moral en quelque
sorte pour reprendre le vocabulaire de
philosophie politique de l'époque il
s'agissait de solidifier la république
et au fond plus d'un siècle plus tard il
ne s'agit plus de solidifier la
république dans le contexte qui est le
nôtre en tout cas par rapport aux
menaces qui était celle de la fin du 19e
siècle ou aux interrogations de l'époque
mais il ya quand même un projet
républicain à repenser au tour on va
dire des valeurs républicaines les le mc
par exemple mérite certainement d'être
revaloriser c'est un peu parfois une
variable d'ajustement dans les cours
notamment les cours
d'histoire-géographie donc il mérite
d'être confortées mais je crois aussi
que la république elle se conforte
lorsque ces promesses sont réalisés et
donc la république elle se comportera
aussi lorsque l'école sera plus forte et
qu'elle pourra mieux répondre aussi aux
questions dont je parlais précédemment
c'est à dire celles qui relèvent des
inégalités sociales lorsque l'école
répond mieux à cela au fond c'est la
république qui s'en trouve conforté la
république elle est aussi elle va s'y où
elle se trouve fragilisée
lorsque les inégalités sociales ne sont
pas corrigés lorsque l'école ne parvient
plus pour des raisons qui ne tiennent
pas seulement à l d'ailleurs à répondre
à la promesse et aux espoirs qui sont
celles qui sont légitimement ceux des
familles les espoirs de progression
sociale des espoirs d'amélioration de sa
condition et donc moi j'y suis très
sensible à cette donne et je suis issu
de d'un monde qui était le monde paysan
du côté de mes grands parents du centre
de la france
et d'un monde qui était un monde de
cheminots du côté de l'afrique de
l'ouest est donc la question de la de
l'ascension sociale cette question là
elle me elle me parle de façon
évidemment très très directe et donc oui
je pense que refaire république c'est
pas simplement
répété en quelque sorte
notre devise républicaine ou l'inculquer
mais c'est aussi montrer qu'elle est
valable et qu'elle est valable pour tous
et toutes et dans tous les territoires y
compris les territoires d'outre-mer
d'ailleurs
sur le job dating
encore une fois je n'ai pas une
expression que je
reprends à mon compte et le fait de je
crois que c'était vous pardon madame la
députée frigo qui posait la question
vous avez en effet souligné le fait que
des classes ferment dans le monde rural
c'est exact c'est factuellement exact
mais cela n'est pas lié à au
dédoublement des classes de cp et ce1
henry peyret plus les fermetures de
classes qui d'ailleurs se nous procédons
à des fermetures de classes on en ouvre
mais on enferme aussi
c'est lié à un phénomène sur lequel j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion enfin que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'évoquer c'est la baisse la
baisse démographique tout à fait
préoccupante d'ailleurs
puisque on entre dans une classe d'âge
très creuse nous perdons soixante sept
mille élèves entre la rentrée 2021 et la
rentrée 2022 et cela va s'accentuer dans
les années à venir un jeu on est on
parle de pour le quinquennat d'un d'une
baisse de près d'un demi million
d'élèves de c'est tout à fait
considérable
c'est vrai à peu près partout avec
quelques exceptions et donc ça ça veut
dire que nous allons en effet procéder à
des fermetures de classes mais en le
faisant avec évidemment beaucoup de
discernement il serait absurde de
procéder à des fermetures de classes
dans un monde rural un peu isolé de la
même manière que dans des mondes urbains
compte compte tenu de l'environnement
général mais il faut considérer cela
moins cinq cent mille élèves dans les
années à venir c'est un fait qui est
tout à fait incontournable
et de ce point de vue là nous nous en
tirerons des conséquences mais nous le
ferons avec tout le discernement
possible les tests de fluence je crois
que c'était vous madame la députée piron
pardonnez moi aussi je fais erreur oui
c'est j'ai été il se trouve que dans une
école de l'orne que j'ai visité
récemment j'ai ité on m'a montré selon
quoi consistait ce le travail sur
l'affluence c'est à dire sur la capacité
à lire de manière fluide au delà de la
compréhension
des
des textes et donc j'ai été sensibilisé
à cette question et à cette
expérimentation qui est faite aux à
l'échelle de l'académie de normandie sur
l'affluence comme élément important dans
la maîtrise de la langue française
pour nos élèves du premier cycle
j'ajoute à cela ce que nous faisons pour
les classes de 6e
avec
la disons la limitation des effectifs
pour les classes de 6e les évaluations
et puis ce à quoi nous réfléchissons
c'est-à-dire à à faire de telle sorte
que l'entrée en 6ème représente une
marche moins haute pour les élèves qui
sont en difficulté qu'elle ne l'est
actuellement sur l'enseignement
professionnel monsieur le député le
grave je crois excusez moi
c'était un c'est moi qui ai mal
retranscrits votre nom mes excuses
nous le
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
garde la pleine maîtrise des lycées
professionnels
il faut que les choses soient claires à
ce sujet et le fait que
madame
la ministre déléguée à la formation
professionnelle et à l'enseignement
professionnel soit à cheval si je puis
dire sur le ministère de l'éducation
nationale et sur le ministère du travail
ne signifie pas que le ministère du
travail prend la main si je puis dire
sur les lycées professionnels mais
simplement que la question des stages
qui est une question tout à fait
importante doit être saisie avec le
concours du ministère du travail et donc
ce et donc la question qui est la nôtre
c'est celle de la meilleure formation
possible
et de la valorisation des lycées
professionnels
c'est l'objet de la loi qui sera
proposée à la représentation nationale
mais il est clair que les quelque six
cent mille élèves lycéens en lycée
professionnel reste dans le giron du
ministère de l'éducation nationale il y
a une carte des lycées professionnels
il ya aussi des des choix à faire entre
des spécialités qui sont extrêmement
demandé très valorisante et puis
d'autres qui sont plus marginales ou
qu'ils trouvent moins leur place il ya
tout un travail à faire pour valoriser
les lycées professionnels
mais il est clair que les lycées
professionnels restent dans le giron du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
cela est tout à fait évident et la
transversalité que j'évoquais à
l'instant n'a pour objet que d'améliorer
la formation et en particulier les
stages de nos lycéens
sur
l'affirmation peut être des principes
républicains je crois que c'était votre
question monsieur le député oudoul cette
affirmation allez allez forte via
les programmes de m6
dont je parlais récemment via la charte
de la laïcité pour ce qui concerne cette
question
via aussi les comités de valeurs de la
république qui existent dans chaque
académie et que nous renforçons
d'ailleurs selon les besoins et selon
les académies qui viennent en appui
lorsqu il y à des signalements aux
écoles et aux établissements scolaires
vous avez fait allusion à la hausse des
signalements qui est en effet exact la
hausse des signalements que vous les 14
% que vous signalez concerne 1 c'est un
type spécifique de signalements ce sont
les signalements pour vêtements pour
tenue et non pas l'ensemble des
signalements puisqu'on était en tout cas
pour la période de janvier à mars dans
une situation de stabilité globale avec
une hausse de 14% pour les tenues à
caractère religieux ce qui enfreint
évidemment la loi de 2004 nous sommes
très vigilants sur ces questions et il
est hors de question de baisser la garde
sur ces questions mais nous ne faisons
pas de cette question une question
politique global au delà de l'école je
suis ministre de l'éducation nationale
et donc je m'en tiens à mon champ à ma
fonction qui est celle de faire
respecter les principes républicains
les principes de laïcité dans l'école
dans les établissements scolaires et
d'assurer les équipes au niveau
académique comme dans les établissements
concernés de la tension et du soin qui
est mis sur cette question par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale sur
les enseignants contractuels vous avez
raison en effet madame la députée
melchior il est des enseignants
contractuels qui choisissent de l'être y
compris c'est un regret évidemment après
avoir réussi un concours d'enseignement
mais qui choix qui ne choisissent pas
d'intégrer la fonction publique pour
risques et dans leur région d'origine
c'est le cas notamment des enseignants
ultramarins qui face à la perspective de
devoir déménager à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres préfèrent garder leur statut
d'enseignants contractuels et je me suis
entretenu à ce sujet avec les députés
ultramarins mais cette question peut
concerner aussi d'autres enseignants
dans différentes régions de france et
nous avons est en effet un certain
nombre de cas dans
un certain nombre de cas
qui confirme vos propos nous avons aussi
des obligations qui sont des obligations
nationales pour un concours national et
en réponse au député
maillot qui m'interrogeait
engagé cet après midi j'ai indiqué que
nous nous penchons cas par cas sur les
situations en particulier les situations
les plus tendues du côté des enseignants
ultramarins mais qu' il faut aussi
réfléchir et aller un petit peu plus
loin dans le cadre aussi de la réflexion
que nous menons sur le métier
d'enseignant sur les sur le lien qui lie
à entre ses premières affectations où
ces affectations après une première
carrière et les déplacements
géographiques
c'est en effet une question qui est une
question importante et qui est et prend
toute sa place dans la réflexion que
j'ai indiquées sur les langues
régionales
je crois que c'était la question signé
d'autres votre question monsieur le
député alors peut-être je ne sais pas si
vous faisiez allusion à la langue basque
puisque pas seulement mais je pensais à
la langue basque
puisque nous avons été amenés à
réfléchir à propos après avoir été
interpellé à propos de la langue basque
de la place de la langue basque dans le
brevet des écoles ainsi qu'à propos des
cols
primaires situées dans cette région et
de la question du bilinguisme
j'ai indiqué que nous ne voulions pas
réagir sous la pression immédiate à
quelques jours du brevet et que nous
allions engager une réflexion avec les
élus basques en particulier sur le sujet
et d'une manière générale sur les
langues régionales ma position
personnelle ma position philosophique
c'est une position je veux dire de bien
intérêt bienveillant pour les langues
régionales je ne considère pas que les
langues régionales soit un obstacle à la
langue française la langue française
c'est la prunelle de nos yeux bien
entendu et on ne doit rien faire qui
puisse la compromettre néanmoins le
bilinguisme le développement des langues
régionales c'est vrai aussi du côté des
autres maires ne me semble pas être en
tant que tel une menace ou une de nature
à fragiliser
l'apprentissage de la langue française
on a plutôt des études qui vont
d'ailleurs dans l'autre sens ça c'est ma
position de principe mais nous avons
indiqué du côté du rectorat d'aquitaine
que nous engagions des échanges sur ce
sujet pour aboutir à une solution
d'équilibré en veillant tout de même à
ce que la langue française qui est la
langue officielle de la république
conserve sa place et tout sa centralité
bien entendu
merci
non mais c est en constante amélioration
donc tu vois bien là nous allons prendre
nous avons encore 30 députés inscrits
donc je propose que nous faisions deux
salves de questions de 15 et 15 avec le
ministre qui s'engage à répondre
vraiment de façon
concise mais sachant qu'il aura déjà
répondait à une grande partie des
questions
puisque c'est mais voilà donc je vous
annonce quand même tout
comme ça donc stéphane mazars pour une
minute
et je serai intransigeante
merci mais la présidente monsieur le
ministre il ya un peu plus de deux ans
madame salon et berlioux s'est vu
confier à la demande de votre
prédécesseur une mission orientations et
égalité des chances de la france des
zones rurales et des petites villes le
constat de son rapport remis le 5 mars
2020 est clair les jeunes des zones
rurales et des petites villes ne sont
pas dans la même situation de départ
face à leur avenir que les jeunes des
grandes métropoles ce qui entraîne des
conséquences individuelles et
collectives graves notamment en matière
de cohésion nationale selon la
rapporteure salon et berlioux ce sont 10
millions de jeunes qui potentiellement
sont concernés par ce que vivent dans
cette france rurale et périphériques
monsieur le ministre quelles réflexions
vous inspirent ces freins à l'égalité
des chances et à la mobilité sociale
mise en évidence dans ce rapport et
quelles sont les mesures qui vous
semblent devoir être mise en oeuvre en
priorité pour restaurer la promesse
républicaine en tous lieux de notre
territoire
merci monsieur le député les ovales
terre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre il y a quelques semaines à
peine je faisais encore partie de ces
professionnels ayant la conscience d'une
mission assez vaste pour conduire toute
une vie et au delà pour se poursuivre à
la génération suivante selon les termes
de votre lettre en professeur du 27 juin
dernier en d'autres termes j'étais
maître d'école cette conscience est
toujours aussi vive aujourd'hui cette
mission je compte bien la poursuivre en
tant que parlementaire la question que
j'allais vous posez a été largement
évoquée dans les interventions de mes
collègues députés et vous y avait donc
déjà répondu je l' ai donc modifié
malheureusement j'ai l'impression que
vos réponses n'en sont pas d'une part
j'ai entendu des éléments de langage
mille fois entendues et qui semble faire
l'impasse sur tout sur le fait que c'est
votre gouvernement qui est aux affaires
depuis cinq ans
d'autre part vous nous avez annoncé des
perspectives qui pour moi annonce une
dégradation supplémentaire de la
situation ça n'allait vraiment pas bien
et ce sera pire en bref monsieur le
ministre ma question est la suivante re
votre première rentrée scolaire
ressemblera t elle à celle ci mal
préparée par votre prédécesseur et dont
le souvenir est encore cuisant dans les
salles des maîtres où pouvons-nous
espérer le retour d'une école publique
républicaine au service des enfants et
de la jeunesse de ce pays je vous
remercie monsieur le député la parole
est à fabrice le vigoureux
il n'est pas là donc la parole est à
jean jacques gauthier
merci même la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez rappelé l'importance
de l'éducation nationale pour
transmettre les valeurs républicaines de
transmission non seulement des
savoir-faire mais donc aussi les
savoir-vivre respect de l'autre respect
de la différence lutte contre
l'intolérance lutte contre le racisme
mais quelle est votre position
concernant certaines dérives en matière
de censure de cancelles culture des
tentatives de réécriture de l'histoire
il faudrait sécheresse ou au ministre
également l'historien agrégé d'histoire
des tentatives de réécriture de
l'histoire et de relecture de l'histoire
d'hier avec des critères d'aujourd'hui
les attaques abracadabrante par exemple
de colbert ici à l'assemblée nationale
ou de voltaire qui pourtant lui même
lutter contre l'intolérance quelle est
votre position un rapport à ces dérives
du gaullisme le rôle de l'éducation dans
leur prévention
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
ce film est
merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le ministre
vous avez pris position concernant des
sujets essentiels revalorisation
salariale vivre ensemble lutte contre
les inégalités sociales ou encore bien
être des élèves ces aspects se croise
notamment en une thématique essentielle
celle de l'école en zone rurale dans nos
campagnes par exemple en gironde où même
le sud-gironde que vous connaissez
l'accès à l'éducation n'est pas le même
qu'en ville il est peut être rendue plus
difficile par des problèmes de transport
de mobilité par des remplacements de
professeurs moins rapide ou pas du tout
ou encore par des moyens restreints pour
nos écoles rurales monsieur le ministre
qu'envisagez-vous pour soutenir la
qualité d'éducation nationale en
ruralité et l'égalité des chances je
vous remercie merci madame la députée la
parole et à caroline parmentier merci
bien la présidente monsieur le ministre
parcours sub cette année c'est de
nouveau des milliers de lycéens qui
n'ont pas eu de réponse et c'est aussi
des centaines de milliers de lycéens qui
ont eu une réponse qui ne correspond pas
à leur projet de vie candidat en
médecine bachelier avec mention des
candidatures en attente des jeunes
inutilement stressé en période de
révision du bac et pas de place dans les
formations ce système est devenu le
symbole des fausses promesses de
l'éducation nationale je suis mère de
trois enfants et je parle au nom des
parents que nous sommes jusqu'à quand un
algorithme défectueux va-t-il déterminer
l'avenir de nos enfants monsieur le
ministre alors que la jeunesse sacrifiée
est abîmée par les années qu'ovide va
mal pouvez vous m'expliquer pourquoi
vous persistez à maintenir ce système
sans âme et sans discernement qui
conditionne l'avenir de la jeunesse de
france
comptez-vous le supprimer ou à défaut
comment comptez-vous l'améliorer
merci madame la députée la parole est à
jean luc warsmann
oui merci mais l'un présidente monsieur
le ministre charles koffi cité pour le
tome nation est formé le souhait que le
travail initié entre les ardennes évoque
mystère année puisse se poursuivre et
s'amplifier face aux difficultés
économiques et sociales à la baisse
démographique de mon département
d'environ 15 cents habitants par an les
ardennes ont uni leurs forces pour aider
misé département et cette volonté a reçu
le soutien du gouvernement par la
signature le 15 mars 2010 9 du pacte
ardennes dans ce cas de la direction des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale et ardennes unis à ses
partenaires vient de voir son projet
visant à favoriser l'autonomie des
élèves retenu le 28 juin dernier dans le
cas de la paix la mission d'intérêt
innovation dans la forme scolaire je
vais de monsieur nice pourra compter sur
votre soutien pour la concrétisation de
cette démarche porteuse d'espoir je
souhaite également que vous acceptiez de
faire des ardennes une terre
d'innovation dans l'enseignement des
langues étrangères dès et ce dès la
maternelle
l'avenir des jeunes ardennais à
construire dans le renforcement des
relations humaines économiques
culturelles au sein de l'union
européenne à titre d'exemple premiers
clients fournisseurs et comique des
ardennes et l'allemagne merci monsieur
le ministre de prendre en compte cette
volonté des ardennais être en point dans
l'innovation pour l'apprentissage des
langues à nos futures générations
merci monsieur député la parole est à
fabienne colboc merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie pour la présentation de votre
politique éducative et en tant que vice
président de la commission pour le
groupe renaissance je voulais vous
assurer de notre investissement pour
prendre part aux débats dans les écoles
que vous appelez de vos voeux en 2023 ma
question concerne l'instruction en
famille par la loi du 24 avril du 24
août 2021 confortant le respect des
principes de la république les parents
doivent désormais demander une
autorisation au laser avec quatre motifs
possibles dont celui de l'existence
d'une situation propre à l'enfant
motivant le projet éducatif nous sommes
plusieurs à avoir reçu des courriers de
famille qui se sont vu refuser cette
autorisation pour la rentrée prochaine
essentiellement liée aux motifs cités
précédemment il semble que ces refus
sont plus nombreux dans certaines
académies ce qui accentue les
incompréhensions et parfois les colères
pourriez-vous ainsi nous préciser
comment sont examinés ces demandes
d'autorisation et s'il existe une
harmonisation des critères d'évaluation
au niveau national je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
jean claude rault
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre sur le sujet de l'entier de
l'enseignement professionnel qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur et que
vous n'aviez pas abordé dans vos propos
liminaire vous l'avez déjà entendu nous
avons besoin d'être rassuré le président
candidat emmanuel macron annoncé en
effet le 28 mars ce dernier une des plus
grandes réformes qu'il voulait porter
dans les années qui viennent je crains
qu'elles n'aillent bien plus loin que le
périmètre évoquée malgré votre réponse
la double tutelle me pose question le
seul giron de l'éducation nationale me
semblait en effet suffisant pour
garantir l'efficacité de la filière
autre signe depuis le 21 juin un décret
permet aux professeurs de lille ii lp
d'enseigner en collège et en lycée je me
remets pas en cause des réussites de
l'apprentissage mais la voie
professionnelle basée sur une forme
d'alternance plus ou peut aussi
constituer l'école de la seconde chance
il ne faut pas faire de cette réforme
une question idéologique hors de toute
concertation ma question monsieur le
ministre est simple au vu de ce qui
semble être un glissement vers une
disparition délégation entreprise de
l'enseignement professionnel pouvez vous
nous préciser comment vous imaginer
l'avenir du ces professionnels et le
sort qui sera réservé aux professeurs
qui ont choisi d'y exercer merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
frédéric maillot
c'est beau madame la présidente merci
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
interroger sur la situation de la
formation professionnelle dans les
territoires ultramarins des formations
professionnelles ont souvent été perçue
et c'est là demain encore compris ce y
compris chez certains agents de
l'éducation nationale hélas comme des
filières ou de garage pour nos jeunes en
difficulté et en déshérence colère
monsieur le ministre fort et habiliter
les cursus professionnel et
d'apprentissage en créant plus de lycées
professionnels d'excellence sur nos
territoires d'outre-mer aussi et
lectures gens de prévoir un véritable
plan de réhabilitation des
établissements scolaires vieillissant la
construction des lycées nouveaux et
innovants à la réunion pour des lycées
est liée aux métiers liés à la mer liée
à l'écologie biais à l'environnement
liés aux touristes dans le cadre de la
réforme de la formation professionnelle
monsieur le ministre pourriez-vous nous
garantir que l'état sera en appui de la
politique des régions d'outre-mer sur la
réhabilitation construction des lycées
innovants et programmes de formation
professionnelle adaptée à la réalité des
territoires
et comme il me reste très peu de temps
je suis d'accord sur les langues
régionales
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
christophe marion
le micro
monsieur maillot le merci merci madame
la présidente je souhaitais vous
interrogez monsieur le ministre sur
l'application d'une promesse faite par
le président de la république en mars
dernier monsieur le président avait en
effet annoncé vouloir consacrer une demi
journée d'école par semaine à
l'orientation pour tous les collégiens
de la 5e à la 3e cette demi-journée
alors par semaine ou par mois en fait
c'est une première précision que je
souhaiterais obtenir cette demi journée
devant être aussi l'occasion pour les
collégiens de visiter les entreprises
proches de leur établissement afin de
découvrir des secteurs d'activité et des
métiers monsieur le ministre je
souhaitais donc savoir si cette mesure
était bien à retordre du jour et selon
quel calendrier une concertation est
elle programmée ou en cours
particulièrement avec les professeurs de
technologie qui seraient les plus
impactés les plus mobilisés cette nuit
cette mesure signifie thiel d'ailleurs
l'arrêt total des cours de technologie
dans leur forme actuelle et comment
imaginez-vous enfin la relation
établissements entreprises dans les
territoires en tension de recrutement
comme d'ailleurs dans les territoires en
manque de vitalité économique
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
cécile gril ac
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre la loi créant la fonction de
directrice ou de directeur d'école a été
promulguée le 21 décembre dernier ce
texte vise à améliorer les conditions de
travail nos directeurs d'école
reconnaissons juridiquement l'existence
de la fonction et en leur donnant plus
de temps et plus de moyens pour se
consacrer à leur mission première
piloter leur école et organiser la vie
de l'école de ses acteurs si nos
directrices et directeurs d'école se
réjouissent du vote de cette loi ils
restent dans l'attenté de la publication
des décrets qui permettront de préciser
les contours et apporter les
dispositions contenues dans ce texte
monsieur le ministre nous devons aller
au bout de nos ambitions pour notre
école
quand aurons-nous la traduction
réglementaire de la délégation de
compétence de l'autorité académique
le ministère at il travaillé sur un
outil permettant le vote électronique
aux élections parents d'élèves ac l
avancement accéléré pourront prétendre
des directrices et les directeurs
d'école comment pourra se décliner
l'aide matérielle les moyens numériques
ou encore l'aide humaine nécessaire à
l'exercice de leurs fonctions le
président de la république a fait de
l'enseignement du premier degré une
priorité et la direction d'école en est
un maillon essentiel aussi monsieur
ministre pourriez-vous nous fournir des
indications quant à la publication des
décrets tant attendu pour améliorer
leurs conditions de travail je vous
remercie merci madame la députée parole
est à christine loire
bonjour bonjour monsieur le ministre
tandis que l'école inclusive était une
priorité du quinquennat d'emmanuel macro
et de jean michel blanquer à vous n'avez
rien fait pour le statut des avs h vous
avez maintenu les avais sage dans une
grande précarité
la plupart sont embauchés en cdd de
trois ans renouvelable une fois très peu
d'entre elles obtiennent un cdi de plus
les temps incomplet impose et
maintiennent l'immense majorité des
années sages sous le seuil de pauvreté
avec un salaire moyen de 788 150 euros
nets par mois
comment voulez vous vivre dignement
louer un logement voire emprunter quand
vous n'êtes conseil d'eads et
aujourd'hui il y a quatre cent mille
élèves en situation de handicap
scolarisés en milieu ordinaire pour 125
1501 et sachent chiffres du ministère de
plus elle manque réellement de formation
pour aborder le handicap afin qu une
inclusion soit optimale donc monsieur le
ministre que pensez vous faire pour le
statut les arrêts et sage la
valorisation de cet emploi le salaire la
formation les problèmes de multiples
affectations où on est la promesse du
gouvernement pour la création de quatre
postes pas pour septembre une goutte
d'eau mais mieux que hier si madame la
députée la parole est à philippe fait
présidente monsieur le ministre
une enquête pisa montre que le climat
scolaire en france ni gravement à
l'apprentissage des élèves et 1,8
d'importants retards outre le sport qui
peut permettre aux enfants de
s'approprier des votes des valeurs
d'accepter l'autre est de trouver un
équilibre
j'ai pu mesurer tout l'intérêt de
certaines techniques comme la méditation
à sophrologie le yoga que mes services
ont mis en place notamment en quartiers
politique de la ville portant scolaire
et quand vous le disions quand bull
monsieur le ministre
le bien-être des élèves n'est pas un
sujet marginal aussi peut-on envisager
de recourir aux techniques alternatives
pendant le temps scolaire pour permettre
aux enfants d'évoluer dans les
meilleures dispositions pour apprendre
et respecter l'institution
merci monsieur le député la parole est
un andric d'avis
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre à la rentrée prochaine sera
donc menée dans 59 l'école marseillaise
expérience expérimentations pédagogiques
voulue par emmanuel macron avec ce
projet qui inquiète les parents dont je
fais partie et les enseignants la
question qu'on se pose c'est est-ce que
marseille va devenir le laboratoire du
démantèlement de notre service public
d'éducation pourquoi c'est d'abord un
coup porté au statut des enseignants la
possibilité donnée aux directeurs
d'école de recruter des contractuels sur
projets ou par voie mobilité et ceci en
dérogeant complètement au dispositif
actuel change la nature de notre système
éducatif ensuite ce dispositif
renforcera les inégalités les écoles
seront en effet en concurrence pour
attirer les meilleurs élèves et les
meilleurs professeurs enfin c'est pour
les enseignants une remise en cause de
leur liberté pédagogique le pouvoir de
recrutement des directeurs l'etat sera
de fait dans une situation de
subordination cette logique de
contractualisation des moyens
conditionnera leur octroie à la mise en
place de projets je connais bien cette
logique que j'ai beaucoup expérimenté
dans la recherche scientifique elle fait
beaucoup de dégâts monsieur le ministre
abandonner ce projet fait confiance aux
enseignants en leur donnant des moyens
pour faire leur travail correctement
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
maxime minot
le micro s'il vous plaît merci il ya
quelques jours monsieur le ministre la
médiatrice de l'éducation nationale et
de l'enseignement supérieur a rendu son
rapport annuel qui pointe notamment le
manque de message n'a été nombreux à le
rappeler ces postes attirent peu de
candidats en raison d'une rémunération
plus attractive mais aussi parce que ces
personnels sur votre rapidement en
difficulté car peu formés depuis de très
nombreuses années une politique de
réduction des moyens et de suppression
des postes dans les rased dans les
secteurs de la santé scolaire ainsi
qu'aux ainsi que du niveau du nombre
d'enseignants en est la cause alors
monsieur ministre pour maintenir
l'objectif d'une réelle et école
inclusive et garantir les fondements de
ladite loi handicap de 2005
qu'envisagez-vous pour renforcer
l'attractivité de ces métiers
d'éducation et que comptez vous faire
pour mieux accompagner ses personnels
qu'ils soient enseignants ou avait sache
notamment en termes de formation et de
renforcement en moyens humains je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député la
parole est à vous monsieur le ministre
pour une dizaine de minutes
je vous remercie pour ces
question je vais commencer par la
question posée par le député
ma'sara propos
d'orientation d'égalité des chances dans
les territoires ruraux
là si on prend donc les écoles situées
en zone rurale il en est à peu près dix
sept mille qui scolarise un million 1,2
million d'enfants
ses écoles et ses élèves ont une
caractéristique c'est que on observe de
bonnes performances le scolaire mais une
plus faible ambition scolaire et
d'orientation c'est cette
caractéristique là qui nous semble
évidemment
préoccupante à certains égards et on
observe d'ailleurs que les élèves qui
résident dans les communes rurales ont
un taux de passage en seconde qui est
des dix points inférieurs aux élèves des
communes urbaines
là
l'expérimentation qui est conduite
actuellement dans 23 territoire pilote
consiste à créer des territoires
éducatifs ruraux ce qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon donc les ter les
territoires éducatifs ruraux qui ont été
proposées par la mission qui avait été
confiée par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale à un rien azéma et pierre
mathiot et donc visant à faire une plus
grande différence dans les politiques
éducatives et donc on prête grande
attention à ces territoires éducatifs
ruraux et donc une politique
qui est une politique
visant à
accorder plus de moyens à ces
territoires éducatifs ruraux et nous
allons poursuivre ces actions
dans les années à venir et surtout
observer
ce qui ce qui advient dans ses nouvelles
dans cette expérimentation qui se joue
dans trois rectorats normandie amiens et
nancy metz
monsieur le député valter à propos de la
rentrée scolaire j'ai dit que la rentrée
scolaire et je n'ai rien caché les
difficultés que nous avons pour la
rentrée scolaire
ce que je veux dire aussi en lien avec
cela c'est que nous avons
renforcé repris relancer choisi c'est le
terme que vous voulez le dialogue social
et que nous avons en dépit des
désaccords que nous pouvons avoir je
pense un dialogue social de qualité avec
les organisations représentatives et
nous allons le maintenir tout au long de
l'automne y compris dans le cadre des
négociations que j'indiquais donc oui la
rentrée sera une rentrée délicate pour
les raisons que vous dites mais ce qui
me semble très important c'est
d'échanger avec les organisations
syndicales avec les enseignants avec les
directeurs directrices d'établissement
et d'écoles avec les personnels
administratifs ça nous y sommes très
attachés à la fois pour des raisons je
dirais symbolique marcon je tiens à
marquer je suis moi-même enseignants la
considération que j'ai pour mes
collègues car je les considère comme des
collègues et en même temps bien sûr pour
des raisons aussi qu'ils sont liés au
fond parce que une politique la
politique de ce ministère ne se fera pas
sans
la participation sans des moyens oui ça
compte aussi 95 % du budget de
l'éducation nationale ce sont des
salaires je vous rappelle au passage
donc c'est une question importante que
celle des moyens mais aussi celle de
réforme celle d'avancer sur les
questions dont j'ai parlé qui se font en
dialogue et j'y tiens beaucoup
monsieur le député à propos monsieur le
député gauthier à propos de relecture de
l'histoire là c'est
vous avez évoqué le cas de colbert qui
dont pardon il y en a d'autres et bien
sûr
là c'est on sort un tout petit peu
peut-être de ma ma fonction stricto
sensu je ne suis pas du tout un parti
sans un partisan de l'efa sage ou de
l'effacement pardon de
colbert ou de qui que ce soit ce qui me
semble important en tant qu'historien
c'est de faire de l'histoire et donc il
y a là un enjeu qui est un enjeu
important
c'est à dire c'est une expression
d'ailleurs du président de la république
lire toutes les pages de notre histoire
ça veut dire quand on parle de colbert
évidemment parler de celui que moi j'ai
appris aussi quand j'étais enfant quand
j'étais écolier mais il faut aussi
parler ça ne veut pas dire retirer la
statue mais il faut aussi parler des
questions plus sombres liée à la fin du
xviie siècle et au grand développement
du commerce de l' esclavage et de la
traite transatlantique
mais pour faire ça il ne faut rien
effacé en réalité voiliers et donc moi
je ne suis pas du tout de ceux qui
préconisent d'ailleurs je les écris et
je me suis exprimé là-dessus qui
préconiserait le moindre effacement de
quoi que ce soit en revanche je suis de
ceux qui suis persuadé qu'il faut parler
de tout en histoire y compris des pages
qui peuvent être des pages plus
difficile c'est ma position en tant
qu'historien
je dirais aussi en tant que pédagogue il
ne s'agit pas de repentance ce n'est pas
du tout un vocabulaire qui est le mien
mais il s'agit de connaissance de
connaissances et puis aussi le cas
échéant de reconnaissance parce qu'il y
à aussi dans notre pays on le sait à
propos des questions d' esclavage par
exemple que je viens de mentionner il ya
aussi des mémoires blessées il faut
aussi reconnaître par exemple par des
cérémonies annuelles comme celle du 10
mai qui est une cérémonie importante
donc connaissance rien effacé regardez
toutes les pages de notre histoire
c'est ma démarche personnelle en tant
qu'historien et je pense que ça renforce
la république je pense que la république
elle se renforce en et en
regardant
les pages de son histoire où les pages
d'avant la république plutôt qu'en les
mettant de côté mais je ne suis pas du
tout partisan de déplacer ou de masquer
quoi que ce soit et certainement pas la
statue et de colbert où les statuts de
colbert
à propos de parcours sup madame la
députée il y a des difficultés dans
parcours sub je crois que je ne sais que
c'était vous madame kim intervient
excusez moi c'était vous qui
m'interrogent y est sûre parcours sup et
ne ma collègue la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur qui est
directement en charge de parcours sup
pourra développer ce point si vous
souhaitez l'auditionner à la rentrée
puisque nous aurons un bilan complet de
parcours ce hub qui n'est pas encore
complet puisque il ya un certain nombre
de jeunes qui n'ont pas encore reçu de
réponse mais il ya encore beaucoup de
place dans l'enseignement supérieur il
ya quinze jours il y avait 94 mille
jeunes qui n'avaient pas de réponse le
ministère s'est engagé à ce que ces
jeunes reçoivent une réponse avant le 9
septembre et il y avait encore cent
mille places dans l'enseignement
supérieur nous ne nions pas les
difficultés qui peuvent exister mais
comme je lé indiqué parcours sud est un
système
perfectible et un système qui peut en
fait répondre aux besoins des jeunes et
de leurs familles que le système soit
sans âme ça je ça laisserait entendre
que le système précédent était un
système qui en avait et ça ça je suis
pas sûr de cela il faut quand même vous
dire qu'on gère des congères des flux et
qu'on gère des masses d'étudiants qui
sont pas du tout comparables à ceux
qu'on pouvait avoir il y à quelques
décennies donc il faut aussi reconnaître
que la démocratisation souhaitable de
l'enseignement supérieur oblige aussi à
considérer des méthodes qui puisse
permettre de gérer des flux d'étudiants
ou de candidats étudiants
considérable sur la
alors j'essaie de 2
sur la loi
rila il ya qu'oui peut-être madame la
madame la députée il y a halak et qu'
ils y ont il ya donc des décrets
d'application
qui sont toujours en préparation
à propos de l'avancement de carrière
auquel vous avez fait allusion à propos
également du décret qui portera sur les
missions des directeurs d'école et c'est
quelque chose que nous allons mener en
parallèle de la réflexion sur l'école du
futur
ainsi que je l'indiquais à propos de
l'automne à venir et enfin donc ces
décrets vont être publiés après
concertation et puis il y eut enfin
point que vous soulignez c'est le vote
aux élections de parents
élève par moyens électroniques
les élections sont prévues le 7 ou le 8
octobre de mémoire et d'un point de vue
technique nous n'avons pas actuellement
les moyens informatiques qui nous
permettrait de garantir un vote sécurisé
pour les
va dire 24 millions
de d'électeurs et d'électrices
techniquement pour l'instant c'est
beaucoup trop risqué et donc nous y
réfléchissons en effet mais ça ne sera
pas pour cette cette fois ci
pour les alouettes sache je pense que
j'ai déjà je me suis déjà exprimé sur la
question des déserts sh2 leur cd isation
comme je lé indiqué on est en voie de
céder lisation de carrière d'adressage
donc sans reconnaître son sans
méconnaître les difficultés nous
engageons quand même avec les avs h un
processus par lequel il se trouve pour
ceux qui le souhaitent celles et ceux
qui le souhaitent céder ise et également
avec un temps de travail parce que c'est
la question qui se pose qui doit aller
au delà des 24 heures la faiblesse de
leur rémunération est liée à des temps
de travail qui sont trop faibles en tout
cas pour une bonne partie d'entre eux à
propos du climat scolaire je crois que
c'était là la question qui était posée
également à propos du climat scolaire en
effet il ya une enquête pisa qui montre
à quel point le la question du climat
scolaire est un élément essentiel dans
la qualité de l'apprentissage c'est pour
cela que la question du bien-être est
posée et a été d'ailleurs comme je le
disais
validé par la plupart tous mes
interlocuteurs
au sein du ministère et au delà ce que
nous souhaitons
et faisons c'est le renforcement de la
pratique sportive une question m'a été
posée d'ailleurs à ce sujet non je me
suis rarement excusez-moi j'ai cru
qu'une question avait été posée à propos
du renforcement de la pratique sportive
de la demi heure
quotidienne dans les lycées
fatigué
et puis également à propos de la
question de la discipline et de
l'ambiance générale dans les classes je
signale au passage que les faits un des
effets positifs du dédoublement des
classes en cp et ce1
consiste en l'amélioration
du climat scolaire et de meilleures
relations entre les élèves et également
entre les élèves et les
les enseignants je mentionne enfin le
renforcement de la lutte contre le
harcèlement c'est un point très
important auquel je m'attache avec la
ministre
concerné c'est la généralisation à la
rentrée des numéros 30 20 et 30 18 la
généralisation des programmes phares et
d'une manière générale une mobilisation
pour lutter contre les harcèlements les
sanctionner s'il ya lieu sensibiliser
les jeunes et lutter aussi contre le
cyber harcèlement c'est quelque chose
aussi qui est en pleine croissance avec
des effets extrêmement négatifs y
compris des effets
psychologiques et psychiatriques je
voudrais dire un mot sur la question de
l'enseignement à la maison qui est une
thématique importante la loi en effet de
2019 dans son titre 4 puisque les trois
auteurs les trois autres autres titres
ne pose pas de difficulté particulière
mais c'est le titre iv qui suscite des
incompréhensions à l'échelle nationale
nous avons 53 % de réponses positives au
titre iv en ce qui concerne
l'instruction à la maison mais là où
nous pêchons au niveau du ministère
c'est que il ya des écarts très fort et
des contrastes très fort entre académie
et département quant aux réponses qui
sont fournis dans certains départements
c'est un nom qui est très massif dans
d'autres dans d'autres départements les
services académiques fournissent des
réponses plus ouverte et donc nous
devons absolument
équilibrer les choses à l'échelle du
pays pour éviter ces écarts je ne suis
pas absolument pas opposé à ce titre
quatre les quatre titres existe dans la
loi de 2019 mais il nous faut harmoniser
et pour cela instruire les services
académiques pour qu'on ait une réponse
qui soit une réponse cohérente et stable
à l'échelle du pays mais je répète que
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
ici et là ça n'est pas un non unanime
quant aux demandes on a plutôt même on
est légèrement au dessus de la barre des
50% y compris pour cette ce titre iv qui
est le titre plus
disons petit peu suscité le plus de
débats par opposition ou aux trois
autres
à propos de
2,2 de marseille de ce qui est fait à
marseille monsieur le député je crois
que c'était vous monsieur le député
d'avis si je ne m'abuse
l'expérimenté l'expérience marseillaise
les expériences marseillaise prennent
leur toutou leur essor à partir de la
rentrée et donc ce que je vous dis c'est
regarder sans oeillères et de façon
ouverte ce qui se fait à marseille et
vous verrez que les craintes que vous
soulevez
[Musique]
n'ont pour l'essentiel pas de fondement
il ne s'agit pas de permettre aux
directeurs d'école de recruter qu'ils
veulent ce sont des commissions qui
inclut l'inspecteur d'académie qui
inclut des enseignants est d'ailleurs le
recrutement sur poste profil particulier
est d'ores et déjà prévue dans le code
de l'éducation nous avons d'un point de
vue réglementaire tout ce qui est
possible pour donner un peu d'air et
pour permettre d expérimentation d
expérience un peu de liberté pédagogique
si l'on reprend l'histoire de l'école
obligatoire laïque et obligatoire depuis
la fin du 19ème siècle il est d'ailleurs
tout à fait intéressant de constater que
des expériences ont eu régulièrement
lieu ici et là l'école n'a jamais été
complètement fermée aux expériences
pédagogiques donc on reprend au fond une
histoire plutôt que de rompre avec un
modèle républicain qui serait celui que
auquel on pompe ans on peut penser
spontanément c'est une pensée la
possibilité d'expérimenter de regarder
ce qui se passe dévaluer de donner à des
équipes pédagogiques aux enseignants la
possibilité de faire un laboratoire de
mathématiques ici de s'inspirer de ce
qui est fait à l'étranger dans une école
que nous avons visité les enseignants
étaient en relation avec des collègues
de finlande pour imaginer des nouvelles
manières de d'enseigner les
mathématiques tout cela ne me semble
absolument pas remettre en cause les
principes de l'école républicaine
bien au contraire et j'ai plutôt le
sentiment que cela la renforce
voilà sur les avantages donc j'ai dit
n'allez pas revenir et puis non
seulement il y aura sûrement encore
d'autres questions sur les avais sache
donc est ce que vous êtes prêt pour un
nouveau tunnel de questions donc on
recommence avec violette inspire vous
voilà monsieur le ministre ma question
porte sur le recrutement des candidats
inscrits sur liste complémentaire du
concours de recrutement des verts
professeurs des écoles ayant été
interpellé par un groupe d'environ 35
lauréats concernés dans ma
circonscription à lille tourcoing marcq
en baroeul bondues et mouvaux dans le
nord alors que ces lauréats d'un
concours exigeant disposant d'un master
ayant effectué des stages n'ont pas de
postes attribués nous voyons à travers
toute la france se multipliaient le
recrutement de vacataires
parfois leurs missions qui ne devait
durer que quelques jours se transforme
en plusieurs mois monsieur le ministre
l'école est le fondement de notre
république française chaque jeune
français doivent bénéficier d'un cadre
d'éducation stable assuré par un service
public de qualité c'est notre devoir de
garantir l'égalité des chances par
l'école et je sais que vous y êtes
profondément attaché aussi pour la
rentrée de septembre avez vous prévu un
recrutement et une affectation rapide au
sein des listes complémentaires des
concours d'enseignants comme cela a été
fait en masse en janvier 2022 au lieu de
procéder à des recrutements de
vacataires je vous remercie
la parole est à yannick haury
monsieur le ministre la décision du
conseil d'état de novembre 2001 relative
aux usa créé un certain nombre de
situations compliquées pour les parents
dans la circonscription par exemple une
élève est scolarisé dans une classe ulis
d'une autre commune que celle aux
arbitres car sa commune en est dépourvu
à qui revient la charge financière de
kylie à l'activité de la rs h pendant le
temps périscolaire et la pause
méridienne la commune où elle habite
ussel web ou celle où elle va à l'école
quelle solution pouvait vous pouvez vous
apporter aux communes aux parents pour
anticiper simplifier ce type de
situation merci monsieur le député la
parole est à claudia rouen
le microbicide merci merci monsieur le
ministre lors de la dernière campagne
des élections présidentielles le
candidat macron aujourd'hui réélu
indiqué qu'il était favorable à plus
d'autonomie des établissements scolaires
sans préciser comme nous en avons
désormais l'habitude le détail de sa
pensée des modalités de cette mesure
plusieurs pays voisins ont mis en place
une autonomie des établissements avec un
bilan contrasté et des modalités qui
leur sont propres au royaume uni le
système fonctionne bien dans
l'établissement situé dans les quartiers
en difficulté
en suède le dispositif ne fonctionne pas
en raison principalement du fait que le
privé peut financer des établissements
publics aussi monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple quelle est votre
vision sur l'autonomie des
établissements merci merci madame la
députée de la parole est à rodrigo
arenas un
merci nous à la présidence monsieur le
ministre
j'ai déjà eu à prononcer sur la question
de la revue les arts et la
revalorisation pardon de la rs pour la
rentrée scolaire à savoir que pour l'art
entre istres certainement et serait en
deçà de l'inflation notamment sur les
fournitures scolaires en raison des
hausses de la pâte à papier la question
qui maquille mamelles aujourd'hui c'est
que la rs comme vous savez ne concerne
pas toutes les familles et que les
classes moyennes notamment les plus
basses par des faits et défaits de seuil
ne sont pas concernés en fait phare des
aides particulières pour la rentrée
scolaire cet effet de seuil se produira
notamment sur les cantines scolaires
notamment sur les ville qui n'auront pas
les moyens de faire cet accompagnement
liée à la hausse du prix de la cantine
de moyenne de 5% à l'échelle nationale
très certainement supérieure dans
d'autres communes et qui dut l'or ne
pourront pas accompagner les familles
quand les quotients se concentrent
fondamentalement sur les tranches les
plus basses et feront l'impasse sur les
classes moyennes les plus on va dire
classes moyennes basses comme on les
appelle cette situation aura une
répercussion particulière dans les
outre-mer où évidemment l'inflation est
beaucoup plus importante du fait de la
structuration de l'importation de ces
matières premières sur chez nos
compatriotes rabat une mère
est ce que vous pouvez confirmer
l'illégalité du versement de fonds dette
sociale pour les élèves du public qui a
tort me semble-t-il a été attribuée
comme étant oui voix et nuit pour le
privé merci la parole est à emmanuel
antoine oui monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais revenir sur parcours sup
force est de constater que le mérite
seule ne permet plus d'exaucer les voeux
d'avenir de nos étudiants depuis 2018
les 840 me candidats à l'enseignement
supérieur se confronte à la plateforme
parcours sur un sondage commandé par
votre ministère et publiée en septembre
2021 indique que 82 % des étudiants la
juge stressant il s'agirait de ne pas
oublier qu'en naviguant sur parcours
super formulant des voeux les lycéens
c'est leur avenir compte tenu des
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent pour se
réorienter le sondage révèle également
que 30 % des lycéens se disaient
insatisfaits des réponses qu'ils avaient
obtenu une statistique est en hausse de
9 points par rapport à l'année
précédente
pire encore 61% la qualifie d'injuste
estimant qu'elle rompt l'égalité de
traitement entre les candidats alors
vous avez indiqué qu'il ya des
difficultés que parcours super
perfectible mais ne pensez vous pas
qu'il serait temps de publier les actes
horribles locaux de sélection in au delà
de ce que vous avez répondu tout à
l'heure à ma collègue comment
prévoyez-vous d'améliorer l'utilisation
de la plate forme pour qu'elle réponde
enfin l'exigence d'égalité d'accès à
l'instruction merci madame la députée la
parole est à cannes olive
merci de votre présence monsieur
ministre merci madame la présidente ma
question fait suite à un échange avec
une directrice de ma circonscription
dans les yvelines au sujet du rythme de
formation sur
le terrain des futurs enseignants ceux
ci sont en effet amenés enseigné à
mi-temps pendant une année avant d'être
titularisé or le rythme proposé par le
ministère à savoir trois semaines en
classe 3 semaines information ne permet
pas d'assurer un suivi adéquat pour les
élèves et leurs parents d'une part mais
également pour les l'enseignant absente
sa classe pendant trois semaines et vous
le savez la réussite pédagogique ne peut
se faire qu'avec un suivi régulier
quotidien des enfants alors quelles
évolutions monsieur le ministre comptez
vous proposer pour la formation des
enseignants ces cinq prochaines années
quelle sera la politique de votre
ministère pour nous attractif le master
mef et améliorer le suivi des étudiants
enseignants et leur formation sur le
terrain
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
sophie tellier polian merci madame la
présidente monsieur ministre une
question sur le collège vous avez évoqué
le fait que le collège avait été pris en
sandwich il a surtout été mis au régime
maigre puisque ces cinq dernières années
ses 8000 postes qui ont été supprimés
pour financer les autres réformes donc
la question aujourd'hui et on le voit
c'est la poursuite de cette politique
d'affaiblissement du collège alors même
que effectivement c'est un enjeu
extrêmement fort pour l'éducation de nos
enfants ce que j'observe moi dans ma
circonscription ce sont des fermetures
de division de hausse continue du nombre
d'élèves par classe et une fuite
également dans le privé puisque les
conditions d'étude se dégrade et donc
beaucoup de familles partent est-ce que
c'est finalement là ne serait ce pas là
finalement là l'objectif de cette
politique donc mon interrogation porte
là dessus et je voudrais relayer aussi
la question de ma collègue kellou
harrachis qui n'a pas du tout reçu de
réponse sur la sur les assistantes
sociales sur la santé à l'école et ça me
semble être une question extrêmement
importante
merci madame la députée de la parole est
à sarah le grain
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chaque jour des parents me
disent devoir renoncer à scolariser
leurs enfants en situation de handicap
dans une école publique monsieur le
ministre que leur répondez vous le
rapport de la médiatrice de l'éducation
nationale pointe le manque
d'accompagnants mais aussi le
morcellement de leurs activités entre
plusieurs jeunes des établissements
alors plutôt que de mutualiser les avais
sache d'augmenter de façon des réseaux
hâbleur temps de travail de bricoler
entre les administrations pour gérer la
pénurie pourquoi ne pas reconnaître
enfin la spécificité de leur métier en
en faisant des fonctionnaires d'état
correctement rémunérés et en en
recrutant assez pour assurer à chaque
enfant un accompagnement à paris ce sont
souvent grâce au jardin d'enfants que
les enfants en situation de handicap
sont accompagnés jusqu'au cp ces
structures publiques avec des
professionnels formés et en nombre
suffisant sont précieuses pour la mixité
sociale comme pour l'inclusion avant de
les menacer de fermeture au nom de la
loi écoles de la confiance comme c'est
actuellement le cas dites nous plutôt
comment vous comptez garantir au sein
d'écoles de la république les conditions
d'un accueil adapté de tous les enfants
en âge d'être scolarisés merci merci
madame la députée de la parole est à
laurent croizier
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre j'ai à bordeaux ville à la
question des salaires des enseignants
pour illustrer l'ampleur de la tâche qui
est devant vous pouvons parler de
déclassement salariale des enseignants
un rapport sénatorial en 2021 démontrent
les enseignants français ont perdu à
euros constants entre 15 et 25 % de
rémunération au cours des 20 dernières
années le constat de l' ocde est
identique les enseignants français
figurent parmi les moins bien payés des
pays dits développés façon générale en
france à qualification égale les
enseignants sont moins payés que les
autres fonctionnaires de catégorie 1 je
rajouterais que les enseignants du
premier degré sont les parents pauvres
de l'éducation nationale recrutés à bac
+5 et sont les enseignants qui passent
le plus de temps face à leurs élèves ils
sont aussi les professeurs qui touche la
rémunération la moins élevée alors après
des constats liés à l'action vous avez
raison c'est un choc d'attractivité dans
l'éducation nationale a besoin et la
revalorisation salariale on est un
élément l'ampleur de mon point de vue
appel à un grand plan pluriannuel de
revalorisation que j'appelle de mes
voeux s'agit de l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant de la reconnaissance
légitime de leur mission fondamentale
nos enseignants sont inclinés
l'essentiel de la république et comme
disait victor hugo cheikh hamad bin
ville de besançon ils sont les
jardiniers en intelligence humaine merci
monsieur le député la parole est à andré
chassaigne
ce ministre département du puy-de-dôme
accroissement des décharges de direction
aux postes dotation cinq postes
conséquence fermetures de classes en
milieu rural malgré l'augmentation des
effectifs notamment 1er pays deux
constats non respect de la loi montagne
numéro 85 30 notamment dans son dans sa
dimension écoles situées en zone de
montagne et non respect d'une circulaire
du 30 décembre 2011 je passe la
circulaire
deuxième deuxième remarque ça c'est un
commentaire le commentaire c'est une
discrimination honteuse je dis bien on
peut 2 au détriment des élèves ruraux ce
qui m'entraîne à 10,2 actions seront
conduites si rien ne bouge tout d'abord
la saisine du défenseur des droits parce
que c'est absolument inacceptable et
ensuite je ministre un bazar dans mon
souviendrai
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
ségolène à mios
est-ce que alors pardon alors la parole
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je vous ai contacté en début de
mandat au sujet de l'école élémentaire
nelson mandela à saint-herblain
le statut devrait plus y réclamer depuis
sept ans seulement comme école orpheline
son collège de rattachement n'en a pas
les conditions et ne peut donc pas
bénéficier du statut votre réponse et je
vous en remercie a été octroyé un poste
supplémentaire et d'inviter au
changement de collège de rattachement
part pour un collège serait plus brisant
ainsi le projet de mixité sociale que
vous qu'il tient tant à coeur
monsieur le ministre vous comptez vous
que comptez vous faire pour ses dizaines
d'écoles d'orphelinats travers la france
mal rattachés pourquoi refuser le statut
de ré plus dans les écoles élémentaires
de nos quartiers pauvres et je tiens ici
à saluer et féliciter ces enseignants et
enseignantes et personnels éducatifs
qui se battent pour leurs élèves avec
peu de moyens
et qui malgré tout tienne le coup mais
pourquoi refuser à ces enfants souvent
allophones l'accès à d'autres
établissements que ceux des quartiers
pauvres je le répète qu'en est il de la
mixité sociale
merci madame la députée la parole est à
alexis corbière
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre ma question portera sur
l'association non mais le choix de
l'école qui est partenaire de
l'éducation nationale et en particulier
dans l'académie de créteil depuis 2016
et à petit dans mon département la seine
saint denis sur les aspects financiers
le choix d'école et non seulement
subventionné par des aides publiques de
votre ministère au moins un million
d'euros en 2019 selon la presse et
revendique aussi de soutien de mécènes
de grands mécènes tels bnp paribas à la
fondation de france la société générale
ne voyez vous pas dans ce mélange la
crainte d'un prosélytisme libéral
dois-je rappeler que cette association
au pacte fut longtemps présidé par le
président de l'institut montaigne qui a
participé à la campagne de monsieur
macron carpes et des notes pour
critiquer d'autres candidats et qui a dû
démissionner dernièrement en raison de
certains ce canal sur lequel je ne
m'étendrai pas ne voyez vous pas la lave
roman semant une certaine forme de la
laïcité puis des intérêts privés par ce
biais sont tentant de pénétrer dans
l'école publique concernant la formation
des jeunes diplômés qu'elle sélectionne
quatre semaines seulement pourquoi être
partenaire d'une association qui
privilégie une formation si réduit
plutôt que le recours à des enseignants
diplômés des métiers de l'éducation
nationale notamment en nombre sur liste
complémentaire enfin pouvez vous nous
indiquer avec précision les montants
actuels des subventions publiques
accordées aux choix de l'école en 2001
en 2022 et ma question est simple
allez-vous rompent ou continuer ce
partenariat qui pour notre part nous
semble assez scandaleux merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
dino cinieri
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je souhaite revenir sur les
aveugles sèche
chaque année avec celui bonne et nous
recevons notre permanence au matin des
parents en colère car ils ne parviennent
pas à trouver des oeuvres sache pour
leurs enfants le 25 juillet 2022 vous
avez présidé un comité national de fui
de l'école inclusive pourrez vous
monsieur ministre garantir que cette
année aucun enfant en situation de
handicap ne se trouvera sa solution à la
rentrée et que tous pourront vivre une
scolarité normale prévoyez vous un plan
de revalorisation de la profession de et
sache pour mieux accompagner ces
professionnels dévoués indispensable
allez-vous soutenir leur titularisation
elle supprimait des pôles inclusive
d'accompagnement localisées qui ne leur
permet pas de travailler dans des
conditions satisfaisantes avec les
enfants et puis allez vous prévoir une
augmentation de salaire actuellement de
850 euros par mois de la formation et un
recrutement merci public merci monsieur
le député la parole est à valérie bazin
malgrain merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je souhaite à mon
tour vous interroger sur le manque
d'effectifs et les 4000 postes non
pourvus qui va impacter fortement la
rentrée prochaine je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur les écoles et les
collèges en zone rurale qui eux aussi
sont touchés par ce manque d'effectif ce
qui engendre des fermetures de classes
des non remplacements de professeurs au
collège et dans les matières
fondamentales est prioritaire
les exemples sont nombreux dans ma
circonscription de l'aube des fermetures
de classes en primaire et au collège au
10e d'élèves près pendant et des
remplacements de professeurs non
remplacés bien sûr pendant plus de six
mois et pire encore des élèves devant
aller ans en classes préparatoires vont
devoir faire la rentrée en grande
section de maternelle faute de
professeurs suffisant dans l'école alors
vous avez pris des engagements
concernant les territoires urbains et
occuper dès que comptez vous faire pour
les zones rurales monsieur le ministre
qui sont trop souvent oubliée je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à pierre dharréville
merci madame la présidente de donner la
parole et de m'inscrire dans votre
commission monsieur le ministre l'année
dernière s'est terminée dans une tension
croissante une égard aux difficultés à
remplacer les enseignants absents ça a
été le cas aux quatre coins de ma
circonscription et avec des inquiétudes
concernant le
la nouvelle carte scolaire et les
fermetures les fermetures de classes il
manque des enseignants dans notre pays à
mettre devant les enfants y compris pour
leur offrir de meilleures conditions
d'apprentissage donc ma première
question sera de savoir comment vous
entendez répondre à cette question là et
je voudrais insister sur les candidats
qui ont été admis sur liste
complémentaire à ma connaissance il n'y
en a 700 qui ont été admis sur liste
complémentaire un certain nombre se voit
déjà proposé des postes de contractuels
ce qui me semble être une très mauvaise
manière de commencer à répondre à la
question posée et deux jours et savoir
si vous envisagez de recruter ces
candidats ali sur liste complémentaire
dont nous avons besoin
merci monsieur le député monsieur le
ministre la parole est à vous et je vous
indique chers collègues que si jamais le
ministre ne pouvait pas aller au bout de
toutes les réponses il s'engage à vous
les faire par écrit
absolument merci madame la présidente
plusieurs questions sur les listes
complémentaires mais nous recrutons déjà
sur liste complémentaire
je lis indiqué précédemment en laissant
au jury le soin de déterminer le niveau
mais nous nous faisons déjà appel aux
listes complémentaires et
malheureusement ça ne suffit pas je ne
recrutons pas des enseignants
contractuels parce que ça nous plairait
gelé indiqué c'est parce que nous
n'avons pas le choix les lis que les
listes complémentaires ça ne suffit pas
les incitations à venir vers versailles
ou vers créteil je veux dire les
académies ça ne suffit pas il y a par
ailleurs des difficultés locales bien au
delà de la région parisienne
la décision a été prise bien avant mon
arrivée d'ailleurs de recrutement est
justement prise de recrutement sur liste
complémentaire
à propos de
d ars h alors je vais plusieurs
questions et on voit à quel point cette
question est importante
je vous propose plutôt que de revenir
sur des éléments que j'ai indiquées d'y
répondre par écrit de manière un peu
complète
je
souligne évidemment que pour nous c'est
une priorité que le recrutement des
avait sache que le fait de leur garantir
un salaire décent et donc plus que 24
heures puisque le salaire de 870 euros
est liée à un faible nombre d'heures
travaillées pour celles et ceux qui
souhaitent aller vers les 35 heures est
également une carrière une construction
de carrière pour les avs ag indiqué que
vingt mille d'entre eux étaient d'ores
et déjà en cdi et ce nombre va
s'accroître même si nous devons comme je
me les indiqué engager une réflexion
aussi sur la meilleure manière
d'accompagner les enfants à besoins
particuliers
sur la question des ars monsieur le
député arenas
là là que les ars
la rs bénéficie d'une revalorisation de
4%
qui a été incluse d'ailleurs dans le
projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat
il y a par ailleurs comme je l'aï
indiqué
dans l'hémicycle plus tôt aujourd'hui
des aides spécifiques prévues pour les
autres maires aide alimentaire et puis
également aides au logement
il nous faut réfléchir
pour la rentrée 2023 à la meilleure
manière d'aider les familles
nous alors il ya déjà des choses qui
sont faites du côté des fournitures avec
le soutien à des associations de parents
qui effectuent des achats groupés de
fourniture avec également la publication
d'une liste type de fourniture et la
demande instante faite aux professeurs
de d'être très ajustée dans leurs
demandes de fournitures et si possible
aussi d'étaler les les fournitures parce
qu'on n'a pas besoin forcément de toutes
les fournitures dans la première semaine
de la rentrée
sur le
monsieur le député chassaigne jeu nous
allons nous pencher
jeu
connais pas exactement la situation à
laquelle vous faites allusion et
vous
vous avez promis en cas de non réponse
beaucoup de
remue c'était quoi le mot de bazar voila
voila et donc je
très bien et donc je je je je vais faire
de telle sorte que le bazar que vous
promettez ne se concrétise pas on va
regarder je ne connais pas exactement la
situation à laquelle vous faites
allusion il en va de même je crois pour
une autre question relative à une
autre circonscription je suis désolé
j'ai perdu le fil de la personne du
député qui l'interrogeait à propos d'une
circonscription et d'un cas spécifiques
à propos des colleurs pheline oui c'est
vous madame la députée
tout à fait
oui c'est en effet un des difficultés de
l'éducation prioritaire qui est une
éducation par zones plutôt que par
ciblage d'école est alors une première
réponse avait été fournie avec l'éclat
si ma mémoire est bonne avec les
contrats locaux d'accompagnement qui
visait à répondre de façon spécifique à
des écoles dites orphelines on est
encore
c'est plus que ça
on est encore en phase expérimentale
pour les contrats locaux
d'accompagnement donc ça se joue pour
l'instant à une échelle très réduite
donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'on parle de
la même chose en l'occurrence
mais il est évident que la question des
écoles orpheline doit être prise en
compte en ce qui concerne les
les écoles et l'enseignement prioritaire
en règle générale
je je vous invite à regarder du côté des
contrats locaux d'accompagnement et je
peux vous fournir une réponse
très bien je le jeu note nous allons
vous répondre à ce sujet à propos de
l'association le choix de l'école
monsieur le député corbières je n'ai g8
dire de cette association ce que je peux
vous dire c'est deux choses 1 nous
allons regarder et faire un bilan de ce
qui est fait et 2 la politique de
subvention du ministère aux associations
n'a aucune raison d'être dissimulé et
donc nous pouvons tout à fait indiquée
les montants des subventions que le
ministère accorde aux différentes
fondations qui le soutient
c'est je n'y vois pas d'inconvénient
de deux principes et par ailleurs cette
association qui mobilise des étudiants
qui enseigne et j'en connais
quelques-uns qui l'ont fait via via
sciences po je ne suis pas certain que
le bilan de cette association soit aussi
négatif que celui que vous décrivez mais
je suis évidemment tout prêt à me
pencher sur
sur la question
oui
l'ensemble des questions à trouver enfin
il me semble que tous les députés ont eu
leur réponse
donc je remercie non alors alors il ya
peut-être une kim ainsi jardin d'enfants
pardon excusez moi j'étais en train de
me lire parle pardon madame la députée
le grain à propos des jardins d'enfants
qui concerne quelques villes dont paris
strasbourg et je crois une ou deux une
deux autres est en effet un des effets
de la loi de scolarisation à partir de 3
ans
la loi de 2019 que la fragilisation la
grande fragilisation des jardins
d'enfants ça n'était pas l'objectif de
la loi que de menacer les jardins
enfants mais c'est un effet indirect de
cette loi et donc j'ai été sensibilisé à
cette question par un grand nombre de
parlementaires et au delà avec aussi des
mobilisations de famille à paris à
strasbourg et ailleurs nous essayons
gens parlaient également ce matin avec
mon équipe nous essayons de trouver un
chemin pour préserver les jardins
d'enfants il faut trouver un chemin
aussi en échange avec les municipalités
concernées parce que l'explosion
l'histoire des jardins d'enfants est une
histoire qui mérite d'être valorisé et
les jardins d'enfants participent aussi
des missions de service public et ils
ont rendu beaucoup de services et je
peux comprendre que beaucoup de familles
ils soient attachés et donc ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que on essaie de
trouver une solution ça n'est pas facile
et ça ne relève évidemment pas que du
ministère de l'éducation nationale ça
relève aussi des municipalités
voilà bah nous arrivons nous arrivons au
terme de cette audition moi j'avais deux
merci à faire je voulais remercier mes
collègues d'avoir su respecter le timing
ce qui nous a permis de prendre toutes
les questions et puis le ministre pour
la qualité et l'exhaustivité de ses
réponses donc merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre et puis nous aurons l'occasion
de nous revoir très bientôt puisque vous
reviendrez à l'automne pour nous
présenter notamment votre projet de
budget 2023 ou que chers collègues je
vous souhaite une bonne fin de soirée et
puis à la prochaine audition